l'ordre du jour rappelle une déclaration
du gouvernement suivi d'un débat en
application de l'article 50 kyriade la
Constitution sur la politique
énergétique et nous ouvrons donc la
séance et je vais donner immédiatement
la parole à la première ministre
Élisabeth borne
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
l'énergie est au cœur de notre quotidien
chaque transition énergétique a apporté
des changements majeurs dans nos
sociétés
nous sommes en train de vivre une de ces
transitions et nous devons l'amener avec
détermination et rapidité
nous devons l'amener avec justice et de
manière à en faire une opportunité pour
nos vies pour notre économie pour notre
planète
cette transition est impérative
dès 2018 le président de la République a
chargé RTE d'étudier les différents
scénarios devant nous
et en février dernier à Belfort il a
présenté une stratégie énergétique pour
notre pays
quelques jours plus tard le 24 février
la Russie a envahi l'Ukraine
par cette décision
Vladimir Poutine a violé les règles
internationales
agresser un État souverain et déclaré la
guerre à nos valeurs
depuis le Kremlin a montré qu'il était
prêt à tout pour gagner cette guerre
toutes les exactions toutes les menaces
tous les chantages et parmi eux se
trouvent les exportations de gaz
la raie quasi totale des livraisons de
gaz russes vers l'Europe augmente les
risques de pénurie et provoque une
explosion des prix de l'énergie
à cette situation s'ajoute d'autres
tensions
je pense au pétrole conséquence de la
guerre en Ukraine et du refus des pays
de l'OPEP d'augmenter la production
je pense également au tensions sur notre
production d'électricité avec l'arrêt
pour maintenant d'une part de notre parc
nucléaire j'y reviendrai
bien sûr ce sont des effets
conjoncturels mais d'autres s'installent
dans la durée
la sécheresse est fait du dérèglement
climatique par exemple vient limiter
notre production d'hydroélectricité
ce contexte nous impose d'aller plus
vite et plus loin nous devons accélérer
notre transition énergétique nous devons
sortir des énergies fossiles conquérir
notre indépendance énergétique et
décarbonée nos modes de vie et notre
économie
nous devons tous nous mobiliser c'est
notre responsabilité collective
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs face
à cette situation critique notre premier
devoir est de répondre à l'urgence et de
protéger des Français
notre premier défi est de faire en sorte
que nous puissions traverser l'hiver
sans difficulté
dès cet été nous avons pris des mesures
pour sécuriser nos approvisionnements
nous avons décidé de porter nos stocks
de gaz à 100%
cet objectif est aujourd'hui atteint
nous avons diversifié nos
approvisionnements en nous tournant
notamment vers la Norvège l'Algérie et
les États-Unis
nous avons augmenté les capacités de nos
terminaux métaniers et avec le Parlement
nous avons levé les verrous pour
installer rapidement un nouveau terminal
métallier au Havre les travaux sont en
cours
ces mesures ont porté leur fruit et nous
sommes aujourd'hui l'une des principales
portes d'entrée du gaz en Europe
cela donne corps à la solidarité
européenne
nous allons être en capacité d'exporter
du gaz notamment vers l'Allemagne tout
au long de l'hiver et nos voisins nous
livrerons en retour l'électricité dont
nous aurons besoin
dans le même temps notre parc nucléaire
est dans une situation d'indisponibilité
exceptionnelle mes conjoncturelles
elle s'explique d'une part par le
rattrapage d'une partie des maintenance
qui aurait dû se dérouler pendant
l'épidémie de covid et d'autre part par
un problème dit de corrosion sous
contrainte détectée en octobre 2021 qui
a entraîné l'arrêt de 12 réacteurs pour
contrôle et réparation
le calendrier de réparation prévoit un
redémarrage de ces réacteurs entre
aujourd'hui et février je sais les
équipes de d'EDF extrêmement mobilisées
et je leur fais confiance pour respecter
ce calendrier
grâce à notre action grâce à la
solidarité européenne et grâce à la
sobriété j'y reviendrai nous pouvons
éviter les pénuries
dans le même temps nous devons répondre
à une autre urgence et protéger les
Français face à l'explosion des factures
d'énergie en Allemagne en Italie en
Belgique au Royaume-Uni les montants
payés par les consommateurs ont explosé
et les prix ont parfois été multipliés
par plus de deux
de notre côté très tôt nous avons agi
nous avons mis en place le bouclier
tarifaire qui a bloqué les prix du gaz
et limiter la hausse des prix de
l'électricité ce bouclier nous avons
décidé de le prolonger grâce à lui la
hausse des factures des ménages sera
limitée à 15 %, il en est de même pour
les factures d'électricité des très
petites entreprises et des plus petites
communes sans bouclier les priorer
doublés pour nous compatriotes qui se
chauffent au fuel ou au bois des
soutiens spécifiques ont été décidées
ces mesures sont les plus protectrices
d'Europe et nous les avons complété d'un
chèque énergie exceptionnel pour les 40%
de Français les plus modestes qui sont
les plus touchés par la hausse des prix
de l'énergie
mais protégés cela ne se limite pas
seulement au ménage je connais la
préoccupation particulière du Sénat pour
les collectivités je sais aussi votre
attachement à notre vitalité économique
et votre inquiétude pour les factures
d'énergie des entreprises
ces préoccupations se sont aussi les
miennes et celles de mon gouvernement
ces derniers jours nous avons pris
plusieurs mesures en demandant
l'engagement et la transparence des
fournisseurs d'énergie
nous voulons d'abord garantir qu'il n'y
ait plus d'entreprises ou de
collectivités
nous voulons d'autres parts faire en
sorte que chacun puisse vérifier qu'on
ne lui propose pas d'offre abusives
grâce à des indicateurs de prix qui
seront publiés par la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie
pour les entreprises nous travaillons
avec nos partenaires européens et la
Commission à améliorer les aides mises
en place après l'agression russe à
destination des entreprises les plus
consommatrices
quand on collectivité qui connaissent
des difficultés les plus fortes un filet
de sécurité a été adopté par le
Parlement pour 2022 sa mise en place
sera rapide et des acomptes seront
versés d'ici la fin de l'année
comme je l'ai dit devant vous la semaine
dernière je souhaite que ce filet de
sécurité soit prolongé en 2023 et qui
puisse bénéficier à toutes les
collectivités
nous travaillons actuellement à ces
contours précis et nous pourrons le
présenter rapidement
j'ajoute que face à cette situation
difficile j'ai pris la décision avec le
ministre en charge de la cohésion des
territoires de porter l'augmentation de
la DGF à 320 millions d'euros au lieu de
210 millions d'euros prévus initialement
cette hausse la première en 13 ans
permettra à 95% des communes de voir
leur DGF se maintenir ou augmenter et je
le dis clairement aucune collectivité
aucune entreprise ne sera laissée dans
l'impasse
mais au-delà de ces mesures nous sommes
au front pour faire baisser les prix de
l'énergie
alors soyons lucides les prix du gaz et
de l'électricité ne reviendront pas au
niveau bas de la période covid mais leur
niveau actuels ne sont pas raisonnables
ils sont très excessifs par rapport au
coût de production et sont tirés vers le
haut par des craintes exagérées de
pénurie et par la spéculation
nous voulons ramener les prix à la
raison nous y travaillons d'abord en
européen l'Europe a déjà agi une
obligation de remplissage des stocks de
gaz à 80% a été approuvé nous sommes
déjà à 90% au niveau européen et des
règles de solidarité entre traitement
ont été décidées en cas de pénurie de
gaz par ailleurs le Conseil des
ministres de l'énergie a adopté un
règlement qui autorise chaque État
membre à mettre en place une
contribution exceptionnelle de
solidarité des entreprises du secteur
fossile et une taxation des bénéfices
exceptionnels des producteurs
d'électricité
tout cela va dans le bon sens mais ne
suffit pas car il faut aussi agir
directement sur les prix le président de
la République est pleinement mobilisé
sur le sujet il s'est entretenu avec la
présidente de la Commission européenne
avec le chancelier allemand il a
participé vendredi dernier un Conseil
européen à Prague qui a été largement
consacré à la question de l'énergie la
Commission doit faire des propositions
elles doivent nous permettre d'apporter
des réponses à hauteur des enjeux lors
du Conseil européen des vins et 21
octobre
nous avançons dans plusieurs directions
nous allons mener un dialogue renforcé
avec les partenaires qui nous
fournissent du gaz nous devons faire
bloc alors que la Russie tente de
déstabiliser notre modèle démocratique
nous sommes d'accord pour mettre en
place des achats groupés qui nous
permettent d'éviter la concurrence entre
États membres et compagnie gazières la
Commission va présenter des règles qui
permettront aux États et aux entreprises
d'agir de concerts dans le dialogue avec
nos fournisseurs
enfin nous avançons vers l'idée d'un
plafonnement temporaire du prix du gaz
deux dispositifs sont à l'étude le
premier est un prix plafond pour tout le
gaz consommé le second est un
élargissement à toute l'Europe du
dispositif qui a permis de diviser par 3
les prix de l'électricité en Espagne
ce dispositif
ibérique permet de plafonner le prix du
gaz servant à produire de l'électricité
il pourrait
utilement servir de base à une mesure
européenne
nous travaillons en parallèle au niveau
français à d'autres mécanismes pour
ramener les prix à des niveaux
raisonnables
plus largement enfin cette crise nous
invite à réformer rapidement et en
profondeur le marché européen de
l'électricité nous devons trouver des
solutions durables pour offrir aux
Européens des prix raisonnables et
proches des coups de production
nous soyons pas naïfs les années à venir
seront difficiles notamment en matière
d'approvisionnement en gaz
toutes ces mesures sont donc
essentielles pour permettre à notre pays
et à l'Europe d'affronter dans la durée
la situation sur le front de l'énergie
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs si
nous répondons avec force à l'urgence
nous devons dès maintenant préparer
notre avenir
les énergies fossiles ont des effets
dont nous connaissons les ravages sur la
planète elle nous expose à des
fluctuations de prix majeurs elles sont
une source de fragilité dans notre quête
de souveraineté nationale et européenne
mais comme nous en sommes dépendants
dans notre quotidien nous continuons à
les consommer nous devons en sortir nous
voulons être la première grande nation
industrielle à s'émanciper des énergies
fossiles c'est le cap fixé par le
président de la République début février
à Belfort avant même le début de la
guerre
c'est une question de souveraineté car
nous serons moins dépendants de
l'approvisionnement d'autres pays nous
serons également davantage mettre des
prix c'est un impératif climatique
sortir des énergies fossiles c'est le
levier majeur pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 c'est une
protection pour les ménages les
collectivités et les entreprises à qui
nous pourrons offrir des énergies
propres et compétitives
pour atteindre cet objectif il faut un
plan des moyens et des points de
rendez-vous il faut de la mobilisation
il faut la mobilisation de tous car
c'est de la Moby ou pardon car c'est de
la responsabilité collective que vient
le succès c'est le sens de la
planification écologique dont j'ai la
charge et c'est ainsi que nous
construirons notre transition
énergétique
pour réussir notre stratégie repose sur
trois piliers la sobriété d'abord une
production d'électricité décarbonée
ensuite autour du nucléaire et du
renouvelable et enfin le développement
de nouveaux vecteurs énergétiques comme
l'hydrogène des carbonée
le premier axe de notre stratégie c'est
la sobriété énergétique
avec les crises que nous traversons et
l'appel du président de la République en
juillet dernier la sobriété a fait son
apparition sur le devant du débat public
la sobriété ça n'est pas le choix de la
décroissance c'est baisser un peu la
température
décaler ces usages et éviter les
consommations
inutiles
ce sont aussi des actions structurelles
comme la décarbonation de notre
industrie comme la rénovation
énergétique massive de nos bâtiments ou
encore le renouvellement de notre
éclairage public je pourrais égrainer
longtemps la liste des exemples la
sobriété c'est efficace et c'est une
source d'économie pour tous
état collectivité entreprise
particulier chacun doit prendre sa part
et agir à la hauteur de ses moyens sous
l'égide de la ministre de la transition
énergétique des travaux ont été menés
secteur par secteur pour identifier les
économies d'énergie possible sans
impacter l'économie grâce à ce travail
et à la mobilisation de tous nous avons
été en mesure de présenter la semaine
dernière un plan de sobriété complet et
ambitieux un plan qui permettra de
réduire notre consommation énergétique
de 10% d'ici deux ans
j'entends certains se plaindre de
l'absence de mesure coercitives
ce plan c'est la preuve que la
responsabilité collective marche c'est
notre meilleur chemin pour réussir j'y
crois pour notre transition énergétique
et notre transition écologique c'est de
cette manière que chacun pourra
identifier les actions les plus
efficaces c'est de cette manière que
nous actions pourrons remporter
l'adhésion mais je le répète la sobriété
ne s'arrêtera pas à la fin de l'hiver
nous visons une baisse de notre
consommation d'énergie de 40% d'ici 2050
la sobriété est une manière de penser et
d'agir qui doit s'inscrire dans la durée
ce plan est donc un point de départ
c'est le premier pas d'un long chemin
le deuxième axe de notre stratégie c'est
le développement du nucléaire et du
renouvelable
le rapport demandé par le Président de
la République à RTE est remis l'année
dernière nous a éclairé sur les
différents scénarios possibles
pour remplacer les énergies fossiles
même si nous consommerons moins
d'énergie au globale nous devons
produire plus d'électricité pour
satisfaire nos nouveaux usages notamment
la mobilité électrique ou les chauffages
plus performants concrètement nous
devons être en mesure en 2050 de
produire jusqu'à 60% d'électricité de
plus qu'aujourd'hui
face à ce défi beaucoup portent des
solutions toutes faites certains ne
jurent que par le nucléaire d'autres au
contraire voudraient fermer nos
centrales et ne s'appuyer que sur les
énergies renouvelables ce sont aux
demeurants parfois les mêmes qui
s'opposent à la réalisation concrète des
projets
nous nous choisissons de suivre les
experts pas les idéologues nous
cherchons ce qui est efficace pour notre
production d'énergie bon pour notre
économie et protecteur pour la planète
la crise actuelle nous montre l'urgence
de la diversification elle prouve que
nous ne devons pas être dépendants d'une
seule ressource elle révèle que dans les
moments de tension même les apports
énergétiques que l'on peut juger faible
sont parfois décisifs
diversifié est une chance une protection
c'est pour cela que nous devons avancer
sur deux jambes renouvelables et
nucléaires alors oui nous allons
développer massivement les énergies
renouvelables c'est un choix pragmatique
car c'est la seule manière de répondre à
nos besoins immédiats quand il faut 15
ans pour construire un réacteur
nucléaire
c'est un choix écologique car décarboné
c'est un choix économiquement rationnel
car la production d'électricité
renouvelable permet désormais de dégager
des recettes pour l'État alors que les
moyens de production renouvelables
coûtaient 6 milliards de subventions en
2021 il rapporteront 10 milliards
d'euros en 2022 qui seront intégralement
redistribués aux consommateurs
d'électricité c'est un choix de
souveraineté aussi parce que nous allons
continuer à investir dans des filières
industrielles nos parc éoliens en mer
comme celui de Saint-Nazaire ont permis
de construire en France une véritable
filière
il en est de même pour le solaire je
souhaite que nous puissions réinvestir
pour installer en France et en Europe la
production et l'assemblage des panneaux
et développer une nouvelle génération de
panneaux solaires
nous nous sommes donc fixés un objectif
doubler les capacités de production
d'électricité renouvelable d'ici à 2030
nous avons donc décidé d'accélérer le
rythme d'ici la fin du mois vous
examinerez un projet de loi qui permet
d'accélérer le développement de ces
énergies renouvelables notre objectif
est de lever les obstacles
administratifs et d'aller deux fois plus
vite qu'aujourd'hui
notre démarche devra naturellement
s'inscrire dans le respect des riverains
et de l'environnement nous miserons
principalement sur le photovoltaïque et
l'éolien en mer mais pour réussir nous
aurons aussi besoin de l'éolien
terrestre
je connais votre attention à ce sujet
mais je connais aussi votre sens des
responsabilités et je le dis devant vous
nous devons améliorer l'intégration dans
les paysages et mieux planifier les
installations pour rééquilibrer le
développement de l'éolien sur le
territoire et éviter l'implantation
anarchique des parcs
enfin nous allons aussi promouvoir
l'hydroélectricité nous vous proposerons
un nouveau cadre législatif qui
permettra de relancer rapidement les
investissements dans nos barrages sans
passer par une remise en concurrence
en parallèle nous allons moderniser
notre parc nucléaire
notre premier défi c'est le devenir des
réacteurs existants nous prolongerons
tous les réacteurs qui répondent à nos
standards de sûreté c'est pourquoi EDF
conduit actuellement les études
nécessaires avec l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire pour identifier les réacteurs
qui nous pourraient pas être prolongés
au-delà de 50 ans
c'est pourquoi conformément aux
engagements du Président nous avons
lancé un ambitieux programme de nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires le premier volet de
ce programme c'est la construction de 6
EPR 2 dont le premier doit être mis en
service à l'horizon 2035
nous devons faciliter et accélérer le
développement de ces projets notamment
en allégeance certaines procédures
administratives c'est le sens du projet
de loi sur le nucléaire qui sera
présenté en Conseil des ministres début
novembre
je connais aussi la qualité et
l'implication des salariés de la filière
nucléaire je sais pouvoir compter sur
eux c'est l'engagement et de la
responsabilité de chacun que viendra
notre réussite
la seconde étape de notre programme
nucléaire consiste à étudier la
construction de 8 réacteurs
supplémentaires nous devons notamment
donner de la visibilité au secteur pour
embaucher et former nos chercheurs
ingénieurs et techniciens de demain
enfin le troisième volet de notre
programme nucléaire c'est l'innovation
pour bâtir des réacteurs de nouvelles
générations
l'apprend la France a pris des
engagements forts ainsi avec France 2030
nous avons décidé d'investir un milliard
d'euros dans le nucléaire du futur
notamment pour la construction d'un
prototype de SMR en moins de 10 ans
son expertise en matière de direction de
grands programmes sera précieuse pour
garantir notre performance industrielle
et le respect des délais
c'est pourquoi enfin nous travaillons à
nous doter d'une filière nucléaire plus
intégrée et que nous soutenons
l'acquisition par EDF des activités
nucléaires de général électrique
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
troisième axe de notre stratégie c'est
l'investissement dans les vecteurs
énergétiques d'avenir notamment
l'hydrogène au service de la
décarbonation de l'industrie des
transports et du bâtiment
l'hydrogène allie transition énergétique
et industrielle il permettra une
décarbonation massive et efficace de
notre économie même dans les secteurs
les plus consommateurs comme la
sidérurgie et les mobilités lourdes il
fera émerger une nouvelle filière avec
100 à 150 000 emplois durables à la clé
il sera un atout précieux pour notre
souveraineté énergétique
c'est pourquoi nous voulons faire de la
France le leader de l'hydrogène
décarbonée nous nous en donnons les
moyens via France relance et France 2030
nous allons investir 9 milliards d'euros
dans les prochaines années nous
construirons une filière d'hydrogène
complète sur l'ensemble de la chaîne de
valeur il y a 15 jours dans l'Oise j'ai
annoncé un investissement de 2,1
milliards d'euros qui permettront de
bâtir les 10 premières gigafactory
françaises
j'insiste sur l'hydrogène mais elle
n'est pas la seule filière sur laquelle
nous travaillons la décarbonation de
notre industrie de nos services et de
nos usages passera également par la
biomasse par la géothermie par le biogaz
et les biocarburants
nous le savons certaines industries ne
pourront pas tout électrifier et devront
continuer à utiliser du gaz pour elle le
biogaz sera un levier précieux pour
décarboner
mais le biogaz bénéficiera à notre
économie et à nos territoires bien
au-delà de l'industrie c'est une chance
pour nos agriculteurs qui pourront y
trouver une source de revenus
complémentaires tout en valorisant leurs
déchets et en produisant des engrais
naturels
c'est enfin une opportunité pour le
développement économique de nos
territoires ruraux en créant des emplois
locaux et non délocalisables
c'est pourquoi nous nous sommes fixés
des objectifs ambitieux pour la
méthanisation nous les soutiendrons par
des mesures législatives et
réglementaires afin d'en faciliter et
d'en accélérer le déploiement
enfin je voudrais dire un mot de
l'agrivoltaïsme dont je sais l'intérêt
qui porte le Sénat
il existe il n'existe pas aujourd'hui de
véritables cadres au développement du
photovoltaïsme sur le foncier agricole
et forestier
c'est un problème car cela crée parfois
une concurrence entre agriculture et
production d'énergie on relève aussi des
abus qui nuisent à l'ensemble des
filières cela suscite l'inquiétude dans
les territoires pour autant cela peut
être une source de revenus
supplémentaires et un moyen de faire
baisser les dépenses des agriculteurs je
sais qu'une proposition de loi sur
l'agrivoltaïsme est en cours de
discussions dans cette chambre je
souhaite que nous puissions travailler
ensemble pour converger vers une
définition commune notre objectif est
d'établir un cadre adapté pour le
développement de la filière sur foncier
agricole et forestier
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs pour
être réussis enfin notre transition
énergétique doit être pensée et
construite en européens
nous économisons interdépendantes nos
réseaux sont connectés les uns aux
autres les nations européennes sont nous
alliées et nous partageons avec elle des
défis et des valeurs notre souveraineté
énergétique doit donc être européenne
à Versailles lors de la présidence
française du Conseil européen nous avons
franchi un grand pas dans cette
direction les 27 se sont mis d'accord
pour sortir au plus vite de notre
dépendance aux hydrocarbures russes et
pour accélérer notre sortie des énergies
fossiles c'est une étape historique la
sortie du charbon et du gaz se fera avec
l'Europe c'est ainsi que nous ferons
baisser plus massivement notre empreinte
carbone c'est ainsi que nous pourrons
donner plus de moyens aux énergies
décarbonées de demain c'est de cette
manière que nous pourrons résister aux
chocs énergétique
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
viens de vous présenter les grands
traits de notre stratégie énergétique
c'est le cap fixé par le président de la
République depuis le discours de Belfort
un cap vers la neutralité carbone et
vers la souveraineté un cap qui s'appuie
sur la mobilisation et la responsabilité
de tous un casque un cap sur lequel nous
allons débattre dans quelques instants
un débat qui sera suivi de l'action et
des faits avec l'examen dans les
prochaines semaines d'un projet de loi
sur le renouvelable et d'un projet de
loi sur le nucléaire après les
concertations qui s'engagent sous
l'égide de la Commission nationale du
débat public nous pourrons vous
présenter la loi de programmation
énergique climat cadre de notre
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
et pour atteindre nos objectifs nous
devrons avancer avec méthode en
planifiant nos actions en les inscrivant
au plus près des territoires et en les
pensant en européen
je veux le dire enfin cette transition
énergétique sera radicale et rapide elle
impose des changements dans nos manières
de penser de consommer et de produire
je veux conclure en partageant deux
convictions avec vous d'abord la
transition énergétique sera le synonyme
d'un meilleur niveau de vie la sobriété
et l'électrification changeront nos
usages et nos quotidiens c'est vrai mais
c'est pour le mieux elle nous
protégeront des chocs énergétiques et
des crises à venir elle permettront de
faire baisser les factures en consommant
moins nous dépenserons moins je
veillerai à ce que la transition
énergétique soit une transition juste
enfin la transition énergétique sera
créatrice de croissance et d'emplois
elle sera un levier pour réorienter nos
formations et nos compétences vers des
secteurs d'avenir la décarbonation et
les rénovations créeront des emplois
durables dans de nombreux secteurs et la
transition énergétique appuiera notre
réindustrialisation avec de nouvelles
filières françaises et européennes par
exemple pour le stockage de l'énergie
la transition énergétique est une
nécessité et une opportunité nous devons
pleinement la saisir pleinement l'amener
nous y sommes résolus en français et en
européen je vous remercie
merci Madame la Premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
dans la suite de notre débat je vais
donner la parole aux orateurs des
groupes premier orateur le président
Bruno Retailleau pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre monsieur les ministres
un débat sur la politique énergétique
mais un débat s'envote à une heure
tardive est-ce bien madame la Première
ministre à la hauteur des enjeux
est-ce bien à la hauteur des enjeux
quand on voit bien que depuis l'été tout
a été fait à l'envers on nous a demandé
de délibérer au mois de juillet d'abord
sur le principe de la construction d'un
terminal méthanier qui va importer si je
comprends bien du gaz de schiste
américain
on a délibéré aussi au mois de juillet
sur la réouverture d'une centrale à
charbon à Saint-Avold et puis dans
quelques jours on aura l'examen d'un
texte sur les énergies renouvelables et
puis à la fin de l'année peut-être en
début d'année prochaine sur le nucléaire
et puis enfin la stratégie globale on
terminera par la politique une
programmation pluralienne de l'énergie
qui pose le cadre général tout aura été
fait donc à l'envers et dans cette
affaire le Parlement aura eu à délibérer
à examiner des textes et une stratégie à
la découpe sans voir derrière cette
stratégie en avançant dans le brouillard
alors si j'ose expressions un débat
pourrait éclairer les Français peut-être
peut-être mais c'est déjà trop tard pour
l'hiver parce que les décisions qui
n'ont pas été prises qui ont été mal
prises il y a quelques années vont
produire peut-être je n'espère pas des
coupures de qui était prévisible j'écris
il y a pratiquement deux ans un livre
dont le titre c'était aurons-nous encore
de la lumière en hiver c'était avant
l'Ukraine ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que si cet hiver dans quelques
mois nous avions des coupures de courant
c'est pas la photocopie c'est pas la
faute de sa rouge c'est pas la faute je
ne sais quoi c'est aussi vos propres
décisions celle du président de la
République celle madame la Première
ministre aussi
qu'on doit vous imputer et il peut pas y
avoir de stratégie de politique
énergétique sont établir un constat il
peut pas y avoir
des remèdes sans partir d'un diagnostic
le constat c'est un constat d'échec et
très franchement je le dis sereinement
calmement ici c'est plus qu'un constat
d'échec c'est finalement c'est une sorte
de Waterloo énergétique
c'est un Waterloo énergétique parce que
il faudra nous expliquer comment un
grand pays comme la France grand
producteur grand exportateur d'énergie
et notamment d'électricité se retrouve
dans une situation où on en vient à
manquer de l'électricité si cet hiver
est idéalement les français payent cher
leur énergie l'électricité malgré certes
l'argent public des versets malgré
certes le bouclier que vous avez rappelé
il y a quelques instants c'est tout
simplement parce que l'énergie
l'électricité elle est rare et si elle
est rare c'est parce que on a un compli
un bon arrière d'une trentaine d'années
le niveau de notre production actuelle
c'est le niveau la production de 1990
alors qu'on est des millions et des
millions de Français en plus alors que
on va vers une économie avec des
nouveaux usages qui feront appel de plus
en plus à l'électricité c'est ça et vous
avez parlé de d'EDF voilà Florent
national qui est totalement fragilisé
qui atteindra bientôt sans doute le 60
milliards d'endettement fragilisés par
un mécanisme ça n'est pas qu'à vous
qu'on le doit d'ailleurs de la reine ou
finalement ce fleuron français de
l'électricité aura suivanté des
concurrents qui pour la plupart ne
produisent pas un électron d'électricité
certes certes oui certes un bien sûr
bien sûr mais EDF c'est aussi vous
l'avez rappelé un projet d'étatisation
plutôt que de nationalisation il eut
bien mieux valu à mon avis ajouter de
l'argent frais c'est-à-dire
recapitaliser plutôt que de nationaliser
vous nationalisez pour désintéresser les
minoritaires mais si vous aviez ajouté
cet argent qui va servir à nationaliser
pas pour acheter les 16% de minoritaires
mais pour ajouter à la force économique
à la puissance financière d'ef serait
vraiment conforté je pense au DF
Flamanville une blessure mes chers
collègues à la fierté nationale
ça n'est pas votre faute madame la
Première ministre je sais pas ce que je
veux dire mais c'est une blessure à la
fierté nationale à notre ambition
[Musique]
une centrale qu'on devait ouvrir à
l'époque en 2012 qui qu'on a toujours
pas ouvert qui devait coûter quelques
milliards en coûtera sans doute plus de
3 fois plus pratiquement plus de 4 fois
plus où on doit importer faire venir des
ouvriers américains pour pour la soudure
c'est une blessure la fierté française
je le crois et je pense que vous le
partagez mais ce que j'ajoute c'est que
en plus de cette blessure aujourd'hui
s'ajoute une injustice pour les Français
parce que les Français vont devoir à
l'avenir payer les conséquences des
inconséquences de la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron les choses sont
claires et ça n'est pas la politique de
la doudoune qui va vous permettre de
vous dédouaner de cette responsabilité
ça n'est pas possible ça n'est pas
monsieur le président d'EDF à qui l'on
doit la décision de fermer en 2017
14 réacteurs nucléaires ça n'est pas à
lui c'est au président de la République
ça n'est pas non plus au président d'EDF
qu'on doit d'avoir signé un décret
d'avril
2020 vous le connaissez vous l'avez
signé avec le Premier ministre de
l'époque ça n'est pas le président d'EDF
il faut mettre les responsabilités des
uns et des autres en face des vrais
décisions
et
devant cette échec en réalité
énergétique il faut revenir en réalité à
ce qui a pu en être les ressorts est-ce
que ces décisions
ont été des décisions fondées sur une
vraie stratégie je ne le crois pas
ces décisions le plus souvent ont été
fondées sur la politique la petite
politique politicienne
Emmanuel Macron et vos gouvernements ont
été en quelque sorte les exécuteurs
testamentaires d'un accord qui a eu lieu
à l'époque entre madame Duflot et Madame
Aubry pour permettre l'accession au
pouvoir de Monsieur Hollande ensuite il
y a eu aussi bien entendu la politique
de Monsieur Macron avec cette volonté
d'avoir Monsieur Hulot l'éphémère
ministre de l'écologie au gouvernement
qu'il l'a fait qui lui a fait continuer
sur finalement cette cette lancée c'est
la petite politique politicienne ça
n'est pas des décisions qui nous sont
tombées de l'extérieur chers collègues
et vous avez beaucoup parlé d'Europe
j'ai été scandalisé lorsque email Macron
vous l'avez tous entendu il y a quelques
semaines a voulu justifier la fermeture
de Fessenheim il a justifié vous
m'entendez bien la fermeture de
Fessenheim en disant Fessenheim et en
bordure d'Allemagne tout près de
l'Allemagne à la frontière or
l'Allemagne avait choisi une autre
politique et donc évidemment pour fermer
les réacteurs et les centrales
nucléaires et par conséquent il fallait
que la France la ferme c'est exactement
vous pourrez vous faire repasser le
véritable Verbatim c'est exactement la
justification qu'a donné le président de
la République et qui est inacceptable il
acceptable et quand je vous entendais
parler de l'Europe je suis désolé quand
on n'a pas de stratégie la seule
stratégie qu'on est c'est celle des
autres celle de Bruxelles est derrière
il y avait celle de l'Allemagne vous en
appelez à la solidarité vous croyez
vraiment que l'Allemagne aujourd'hui
comme hier a fait montre de solidarité
sur le plan énergétique non mais
vraiment vous pensez vraiment à ce que
vous avez dit
et je ne parle même pas des 200
milliards du bouclier énergétique
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé mais moi je
suis européen mais justement jamais
jamais l'Allemagne n'a cessé défendre
ses intérêts jamais la France n'a
défendu vraiment ses intérêts voilà le
problème voilà le problème mes chers
amis l'Allemagne s'est mis dans la main
la Russie en achetant peu cher le gaz
russe en voulant exporter notamment ces
voitures en Chine et elle a handicapé
l'ensemble de l'Europe et nous on a
suivi parce qu'on croit la solidarité
parce qu'on croit au coup
franco-allemand moi j'aimerais y croire
mais j'attends j'attends un certain
nombre de garanties de nos amis
allemands bien sûr et aussi de l'Europe
ce qu'on demande un prison de la
République il n'est pas président de la
République fédérale d'Allemagne c'est
d'abord à Bruxelles de défendre bien
entendu les intérêts de la France et des
Français c'est absolument capital alors
maintenant il faut une stratégie il faut
donc une politique énergétique
d'abord je dirais que cette politique
énergétique
elle doit
être une constance une cohérence elle ne
peut pas s'accorder avec le en même
temps qui est tout sauf une boussole
sauf un cap pour avoir une politique une
stratégie il faut cette cohérence il
faut cette constante c'est la première
chose ensuite il va falloir jouer sur
l'ensemble des leviers le levier de la
production d'abord produire de l'offre
le levier de la demande c'est-à-dire et
j'y reviendrai notamment la sobriété
mais pas que et puis aussi la
tarification les prix j'ai commencé par
les prix puisque je critiquais la
politique européenne vous vous souvenez
très bien on était dans la même position
ou à ma place et vous à la vôtre c'était
au mois de juillet vous veniez de
prononcer un discours de politique
générale je vous répondais et à l'époque
je vous avais indiqué mais madame la
Première ministre pourquoi ne
faites-vous pas ce que l'Espagne et le
Portugal viennent de faire et c'est ce
que vous nous proposez aujourd'hui mais
on a pratiquement perdu plus de 3 mois
la tarification européenne est une
tarification stupide sans doute qu'elle
a avantagé l'Allemagne elle dessert la
France le président de la République je
l'ai écouté tout à l'heure s'il y avait
deux débats mais chers collègues il y
avait un débat ici à 9h30 puis un autre
débat à la télévision avec le président
de la République qui débattait de la
stratégie énergétique de la France
qu'est-ce qui nous explique le président
de la République il a dit bien sûr il
faut décorer les le prix de
l'électricité du gaz mais fallait le
faire maintenant il y avait même des
dispositifs qui nous permettaient de le
faire de reprendre la main nous Français
mais à partir du moment où on essaie
toujours de jouer une forme de
solidarité européenne mais qui n'est pas
la solidarité parce que la solidarité
c'est une réciprocité on est dans la
naïveté on est dans la naïveté donc je
vous demande nous vous demandons de
sortir bien entendu de découpler une
fois pour toute le prix de l'électricité
du prix du gaz il faudra sans doute
aller plus loin moi je vous demande et
avec mon groupe que vous puissiez mettre
fin à la suspension des
accords en tout cas du cadre
et des tarifs réglementés qui doivent
s'achever au 30 juin prochain je pense
qu'il faut en sortir si vous voulez un
vrai bouclier ça n'est pas seulement de
l'argent public qu'on doit déverser sur
les ménages ou sur l'économie il y a des
décisions à prendre il faudra repousser
j'ai pas entendu un seul élément de
langage sur ces tarifs réglementés c'est
fondamental de même que il faudra
autoriser EDF et les pousser une fois le
pic tarifaire passé a conclure des
contrats de long terme l'Europe c'est
souvent posée au nom de la concurrence
purée parfaite mais au nom de cette
concurrence purée parfaite que que de
problèmes n'avons-nous pas connu depuis
les années 2000-2010 démantèlement d'EDF
tarification du gaz donc moi je veux
bien la solidarité européenne mais à la
condition que cette solidarité nous mène
pas dans le mur mes collègues moi je
suis pas naïf pour moi l'Europe c'est
pas comme ça le général de Gaulle un
cabri un cabri qui saute c'est pas ça du
tout les intérêts du pays et les
intérêts de l'Europe du reste en même
temps en même temps donc la tarification
ensuite la demande ensuite la demande la
sobriété là aussi le col roulé le
Tancarville
le télétravail bien sûr ce sont des
leviers et ça c'est pas une politique ça
n'est pas une politique expliquez-moi
comment en 20 ans en 20 ans nous avons
autant régressé en matière de
flexibilité de la demande de la sobriété
il y a 20 ans l'effacement notamment
auprès des particuliers je vous parle
pas des entreprises ça nous rapportait
jusqu'à 6 gigawatts 20 ans après 06 en
20 ans on a divisé par 10 on a divisé
par 10 parce que honnêtement tempo et
j'en suis un usagé ça marche pas bien ce
que j'ai vous ai proposé où est-ce que
vous en êtes il faut un grand dispositif
national d'effacement rémunéré et
volontaire de l'énergie ou est-ce qu'on
en est il faut accorder là encore la
volonté et la raison et les nouvelles
technologies soyons modernes madame la
Première ministre et puis je terminerai
sur la production sur l'offre il faut
produire plus une énergie qui est quatre
critères qui soient abondantes qui soit
déc qui soit pilotable et qui soit bon
marché parce qu'on ne réindustrialisera
pas la France mes chers collègues s'il y
a pas cette énergie bon marché
compétitive cet élément qu'on a
malheureusement abandonné il faut donc
bien entendu revoir lape des plafonnés
des plafonnez vous l'avez pas dit
l'énergie dans le mixte l'énergie
notamment nucléaire deuxième chose
prolongée tant que la sécurité le permet
les réacteurs nucléaires il faudra
assurer de la visibilité à EDF je veux
que vous engagiez ce soir pour que EDF
on préserve son unité pas de projet
Hercule ou de projet démantèlement sur
10 ans dites-le nous ce soir franchement
madame la Première ministre dites-nous
dites-le nous vraiment vous nous
rassurer vous nous rassurer et puis
écoutez le rapport de Daniel grommy et
c'est pas six réacteurs c'est 14 qu'il
faut lancer dès maintenant les énergies
renouvelables les énergies bien sûr
elles ont le rôle à jouer mais un rôle
d'appoint l'Allemagne a montré mes chers
collègues que quand on investige jusqu'à
40% l'énergie en termes de renouvelable
il faut aussi investir dans du fossile
c'est ce qu'a fait l'Allemagne et bien
non nous on veut aussi une énergie
décarbonée oui sur le pilotable oui bien
sûr sur l'énergie renouvelable mais il
faut aussi là aussi savoir raison garder
et enfin je crois que mes chers
collègues il faudra là encore une
volonté je terminerai mais là ma
première ministre et je conclurai
monsieur le Président en indiquant que
il y a quelques quelques années en 2017
celui qui vous a nommé avait eu un
slogan un de ses slogan c'était pensé
printemps il semble qu’après à une crise
sanitaire et une crise géopolitique et
même Macron découvre que l'hiver ça
existe aussi que être souverain être
souverain s'apaise aussi ce que nous
vivons aujourd'hui c'est ce que le
progressisme a oublié mes chers amis que
c'est la souveraineté nationale qui est
l'horizon indépassable des nations c'est
cela et ce que je souhaite c'est que
vous reconstruisiez cette souveraineté
énergétique pour le pouvoir d'achat des
Français et pour la réindustrialisation
de notre pays merci Madame le Premier
ministre merci Monsieur merci monsieur
le président
de donner la parole à notre collègue
Franck Montauger pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre monsieur les ministres chers la
politique énergétique nationale
nécessite cohérence constance et
résolution le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est que depuis trop longtemps les
gouvernements n'ont pas eu cette
exigence pour notre pays je passe sur
les tergiversations et les étirements du
président de la République en matière de
politique nucléaire alors qu'il nous
faut rapidement actualiser la SNBC et la
PPE vous nous présentez
ces jours-ci un projet de loi technique
ou de me rendre nécessaire centrée sur
les procédures quel est votre logique
pourquoi ce saucissonnage alors que les
Français et leurs élus ont besoin de
lisibilité de partage des objectifs pour
s'engager eux aussi dans la transition
énergétique nous devons collectivement
réussir une transition de civilisation
parce que c'est de ça qu'il s'agit avec
la fin de l'usage des énergies fossiles
carbonées et les mises en oeuvre de
modèles de développement fondés sur la
notion de durabilité dans un cadre de
justice sociale et d'équité mais cette
impératif de long cours beaucoup trop
négligé jusqu'ici malgré de nombreuses
alertes doit être conjuguée avec des
réponses immédiates et financièrement
accessible aux besoins actuels des
entreprises et de tous nos concitoyens
les Français doivent être soutenus
davantage qu'ils ne le sont
par les mesures que vous proposez et ne
comprennent pas que la France ne puisse
pas les aider comme l'Allemagne
s'apprête à le faire pour son peuple
avec un plan de 200 milliards d'euros
sur les marchés de l'énergie des mesures
structurelles fortes doivent être aussi
prises mais j'y reviendrai en fin de
propos au regard des enjeux climatiques
et environnementaux des techniques de
production énergétique disponibles de
leurs impacts identifiés et de leur coût
des incertitudes et risques qu'elle
présente le débat de ce soir doit
prendre appui sur les données
scientifiques et les études techniques
dont nous disposons
c'est donc dans le cadre du dernier
rapport du GIEC et de l'étude de RTE sur
les futurs énergétiques de la France à
eu raison 2050 que je présenterai les
analyses et les préconisations de mon
groupe le rôle majeur que doit selon
nous et dans l'intérêt général jouer le
groupe EDF sera réaffirmé et nous vous
questionnerons sur le projet qui est le
vôtre pour cette entreprise d'ici peu
100% public au nom de mon groupe je
souhaite que vous nous disiez ce soir
quels sont les hypothèses et les
orientations que vous retenez pour
engager sans tarder le pays vers le
futur énergétique dont il a besoin pour
lui-même et à l'égard de ses partenaires
européens et mondiaux dans la
perspective de neutralité carbone à
horizon 2050 la future loi énergie
climat devra confirmer la trajectoire
d'extinction des sources d'énergie des
carbonées
cela signifie fin du pétrole fin des gaz
d'origine fossile importée et
substitution de l'électricité et du gaz
des carbonées à ses ressources
dans la sNDC l'électricité
représenterait
55% de l'énergie finale consommée contre
25% aujourd'hui cet objectif est-il le
vôtre ou antenne dévoue le réviser et si
c'est le cas à quel niveau dans cette
hypothèse à 55% d'électricité dans
l'énergie finale consommée RTE propose 6
scénarios du plus sobre à 555 térawatts
au plus élevé à 754 térawattheure liés à
une production en quantité d'hydrogène
des corbonnés et à la
réindustrialisation profonde de notre
économie l'électrification plus ou moins
rapide des filières et des usages
existants constituent également un
critère déterminant de la production
électrique nécessaire à partir de ces
scénarios quel mixe de production
énergétique décarbonée entendez-vous
proposer au Parlement pour la prochaine
mise à jour de la PPE en cours
les scénarios de RTE recouvrent en fait
des choix de politique industriels très
différents du 50% nucléaires au 100%
renouvelable
madame la Première ministre vous l'avez
dit le président de la République a
décidé il y a peu après avoir donné il y
a quelques années des orientations
inverse de commander 6 réacteurs PR2 et
de lancer les études pour 8 EPR 2 et des
SMS EDF a engagé le programme grand
carénage de prolongation des réacteurs
nucléaires existants sous le contrôle de
la SN à partir de ces décisions faut-il
comprendre que le gouvernement s'engage
résolument dans le sens d'un mix
électrique à 50% d'énergie renouvelable
50% de nucléaires je vous pose la
question pour la clarté de notre débat
et la compréhension de vos propositions
quels sont les facteurs qui ont conduit
à ce choix pour mon groupe le mix
énergétique doit résulter d'une approche
pragmatique s'inscrivant bien entendu
dans l'objectif du 0 carbone en 2050 en
réalité
incertitude et risque au pluriel doivent
être pris en compte dans les choix à
opérer par exemple au regard des
difficultés rencontrées sur de nombreux
territoires pour développer des projets
éoliens photovoltaïques ou de
méthanisation l'accélération du nombre
de projets nécessaires au scénario à
très forte proportion d'énergie
renouvelable nous paraît de plus en plus
problématique
j'indique que dans le scénario à 100%
d'énergie renouvelable il faut
multiplier par 21 la puissance installée
en photovoltaïque et par 4 celle de
l'éolienne terrestre pour 100 GWh de
fauteuil photovoltaïque supplémentaires
il faudrait aller dix fois plus vite ces
rythmes sont très supérieurs à ce qu'on
fait nos partenaires européens les plus
actifs depuis plus de 10 ans en somme
nous capables je vous pose la question
autre incertitude dans le domaine
nucléaire l'affaiblissement en France de
cette filière industrielle au cours des
décennies passées je ne parle pas ici de
l'exploitation mais de la construction
les difficultés techniques rencontrées
aujourd'hui ont conduit à des
interrogations quand à la capacité de
mener à bien les programmes de prolong
sélectionne la durée de vie des
réacteurs existants ou de construction
et de mise en service dans les temps
impartis de nouveaux réacteurs annoncés
l'analyse doit aussi intégrer les coûts
complets de réalisation c'est à dire les
coûts de production d'acheminement et de
flexibilité nécessaire au fonctionnement
du réseau en toute circonstance l'impact
environnemental des installations de
production notamment en ce qui concerne
les sols dans un contexte de zan
que la loi énergique climat a laissé ni
fait ni à faire et il nous faut aussi
prendre en compte les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre en cycle de vie des
systèmes électriques envisageables dans
une perspective hautement souhaitable de
souveraineté énergétique renforcée les
risques liés aux approvisionnements
ainsi que l'existence de filière
industrielles nationales doivent être
intégrés vous l'avez évoqué la question
de l'emploi local pour la construction
mais aussi plus encore pour
l'exploitation doit être prise en compte
et orienter le choix du mix s'il fallait
faire le choix d'un scénario RTE les
critères d'évaluation que je viens
d'évoquer nous amènerait à faire le
choix d'un mix à 50-50 nucléaires 50
renouvelables nous considérons cependant
que la situation énergétique dans
laquelle se trouve notre pays
indépendamment des conséquences de la
guerre en Ukraine je tiens à le
souligner justifie que le gouvernement
pousse tous les curseurs dans le sens
d'un développement accéléré de tous les
modes de production d'énergie décarbonée
pour réussir la transition énergétique
en situation d'incertitude voire de
risques comme je viens de le dire il
faut que nous nous donnions des marges
en matière de puissance installée nous
devons industrialiser les procédures de
réalisation des projets de la
concertation publique à la mise en
oeuvre c'est fondamental de l'État aux
collectivités locales en passant par les
comités régionaux de l'énergie les S3R
ENR dont l'adaptation aux besoins doit
être revue comment allez-vous mettre en
ligne les acteurs sur quel principe
concret repose votre planification à ce
stade le projet de loi d'accélération et
l'énergie renouvelable nécessaire ne
nous pourrez pas à la hauteur des enjeux
et des difficultés rencontrées sur les
territoires dans ce cadre et pour que
l'agriculture contribue à la production
énergétique renouvelable française
sans réduire sans fonction nourricière
première une définition de la
grivevoltaïsme devra être légiférée
comme le Sénat s'apprête d'ailleurs à le
faire nous attendons de connaître la
position du gouvernement également sur
ce point nous devons aussi aborder avec
vous la question du devenir du groupe
EDF du projet que le Président de la
République et le gouvernement en temps
de lui donner dans ce contexte
énergétique pour le moins instable et
cela ne date pas de la crise ukrainienne
dans les faits et le départ du PDG Lévy
en atteste après avoir passé cinq ans à
ne prendre aucune décision à la hauteur
des enjeux le président de la République
et ses gouvernements sont restés muets
sur le rôle qu'ils entendent de faire
jouer à EDF dans le contexte extrêmement
difficile que nous les connaissons
aujourd'hui jamais depuis sa création en
1946 cette grande entreprise nationale
n'a été autant affaiblie
par défaut de pilotage politique
pertinent c'est à se demander si tout
cela n'est pas voulu
significativement l'ancien président de
la creux disait lui-même il est je crois
dans votre gouvernement aujourd'hui
depuis 10 ans EDF a été la vache à
l'aide de l'État fin de citation je
rajoute que les personnels dévoués aux
missions d'intérêt général de
l'entreprise n'y sont pour rien la
responsabilité est politique et
exclusivement politique nous souhaitons
que vous vous en expliquer dans le cadre
de ce débat madame la ministre madame la
Première ministre pardon pouvez-vous
nous présenter les conséquences
institutionnelles et juridiques de l'OPA
que vous avez lancé le statut actuel de
l'entreprise est-il amené à évoluer vers
un épique par exemple quel rôle exact
l'État actionnaire unique pardon va-t-il
jouer une OPA ne fait pas un projet
industriel
quel est votre projet industriel social
et environnemental pour EDF avez-vous et
ces grandesamment souhaitables renoncer
au découpage d'entreprises comment
financez-vous les investissements d'EDF
nécessaires au grand carénage aux
énergies renouvelables ainsi qu'au
réseau de distribution et de transport
et l'effet et l'effectibilité qui vont
avec pouvez-vous nous expliquer comment
et dans quel cadre juridique vous allez
financer le nouveau nucléaire commandé
par le chef de l'État ce financement
sera-t-il réalisé dans le cadre du
groupe EDF ou en dehors
et si oui comment quelle place
s'entendez-vous donner à la production
hydraulique comment envisagez-vous de
préserver dans la durée le caractère
public de ce parc de production pour
terminer je voudrais aborder la
dimension européenne du sujet si le mix
est une prérogative nationale des États
membres le marché de l'énergie est placé
sous la responsabilité de l'Union
européenne il y a là une contradiction
interne qui explique en grande partie
les difficultés que subissent de
nombreux consommateurs français et
européens et ça ne date pas de la crise
ukrainienne
quelle proposition le gouvernement
français va-t-il porter au niveau de la
Commission européenne et de la puissante
DG Concurrence pour que le marché et les
prix payés par les consommateurs
particuliers et industriels reflètent au
plus près les coûts complets sur long
terme des mixtes énergétiques nationaux
nous souhaitons que les tarifs réguliers
de l'électricité perdurent et que ceux
du gaz soit maintenu également au-delà
de la date de suppression annoncée nous
vous demandons de faire en sorte que les
petits consommateurs obtiennent des prix
stables dans le temps et que les chefs
d'entreprise et de la visibilité en
matière de prix de l'énergie sur le
moyen et le long terme je vous remercie
merci
je vais donner la parole de notre
collègue
Denis CMP pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre monsieur les ministres mes
chers collègues avant que d'évoquer la
politique énergétique de la France
il nous faut établir ce que nous sommes
en droit d'attendre d'un système
énergétique
premièrement de la sécurité et j'entends
derrière ce concept sécurité
d'approvisionnement afin d'éviter de les
stages rationnement et blackout la
deuxième exigence c'est le maintien de
notre souveraineté notre système
énergétique doit dépendre le moins
possible de puissance étrangères surtout
quand ces dernières sont potentiellement
instables ou hostiles troisièmement pour
atténuer le changement climatique en
cours notre système énergétique doit
tendre vers la neutralité carbone
à l'heure actuelle force est de
constater qu'il présente malheureusement
des lacunes sur les trois tableaux la
plus visible en ce moment concerne
l'insécurité d'approvisionnement avec le
spectre d'une pénurie d'énergie qui
ressurgit pour l'électricité cela tient
notamment au vieillissement des
centrales nucléaires quant au gaz il
fait désormais défaut aux Européens du
fait de la guerre à l'Ukraine même si la
France en souffre moins que nombre de
ses voisins
ces déficiences nous rendent par
conséquent dépendant de l'étranger qu'il
s'agisse de notre voisin allemand pour
l'électricité en période de pointe ou
bien de la Norvège et du Qatar pour le
gaz enfin notre mix énergétique n'est
pas assez décarbonée car plus de 60% de
nos besoins énergétiques sont encore
satisfaits par du gaz et du pétrole
cela il est vrai que nous faisons mieux
que bien d'autres pays mais c'est encore
largement incompatible avec les
objectifs fixés par la corde de Paris
sur le clim il nous faut donc réformer
notre système énergétique à la fois pour
répondre aux enjeux immédiats et pour
garantir les générations futures à court
terme le gouvernement semble avoir bien
saisi les enjeux depuis plusieurs mois
il était effectivement nécessaire de
sécuriser l'approvisionnement en gaz de
notre pays en trouvant de nouveaux
fournisseurs ce qui a permis de remplir
nos stocks au maximum avant l'hiver à
moyen terme il faudrait toutefois
envisager de produire ce gaz sur le sol
national par exemple avec la
méthanisation
de même il fallait organiser la sobriété
pour réduire les tensions sur notre
système électrique c'est l'intérêt du
plan dévoilé jeudi dernier rappelant
quand la matière les efforts doivent
concerner autant l'État et les
entreprises que les particuliers et les
collectivités territoriales enfin je
salue madame la ministre votre
mobilisation constante et celle de votre
gouvernement
auprès de la Commission européenne pour
qu'elle propose des solutions
collectives aux États membres c'est à ce
niveau que les actions seront le plus
efficaces en matière énergétique car
c'est à l'Union européenne de régler le
problème central posé par cette crise
celui de la formation du prix de
l'électricité ce dernier correspond au
coût marginal du dernier opérateur
connecté au réseau or aujourd'hui ce
dernier opérateur
ce sont les centrales à gaz dans le coup
de production tire l'ensemble des prix
vers le haut aussi faut-il découpler au
plus vite le prix de l'électricité de
celui du Gast pour ce faire devoir
existe soit par le haut soit par le bas
par le haut c'est à dire en créant un
grand service européen de l'énergie
publique et monopolistique hélas cela
relève actuellement de l'utopie nous
n'arrivons déjà pas à nous mettre
d'accord sur la taxonomie
l'autre voix la plus réaliste est une
sortie par le bas c'est à dire une forme
de
renationalisation du système c'est ce
qu'on fait l'Espagne et le Portugal avec
l'aval de la Commission européenne ils
ont ainsi le droit du rang 1 an de
déconnecter le prix du gaz de celui de
l'électricité de fait cela leur réussite
tandis que fin août le prix du
mégawatt-heure était de 660 euros en
France et en Allemagne il n'était que de
240 euros en Espagne et au Portugal
cette dérogation leur a été accordée
pour deux raisons ils sont très peu
interconnectés avec le reste de l'Europe
et ils ont une électricité très
décarbonée
symétriquement cela signifie que l'on
doit envisager la solution
ibérique pour les pays européens dans
l'électricité est déjà largement
décarbonée comme la France la situation
actuelle ne peut en effet plus duré une
fois nos centrales remises un ordre de
marche notre situation énergétique
serait meilleure en faisant cavalier
seul avec le monopole d'EDF plutôt que
dans le marché de l'électricité
communautaire dans le même ordre d'idée
l'ouverture du marché de l'énergie n'a
pas donné des résultats satisfaisants
revenir dessus nous permettrait de
supprimer cette absurdité que la reine
ce dernier a été une belle aubaine pour
des opérateurs qui se sont comportés
comme de simples négociants
engrangeant des profits sur l'argent du
contribuable investi dans centrale il
est temps désormais d'arrêter de
considérer l'énergie comme une simple
marchandise et la prendre pour ce
qu'elle est réellement un bien public de
première nécessité à ce titre il
convient de s'interroger sur la
pertinence d'un éventuel retour au tarif
réglementé de vente de l'électricité et
même du gaz à plus long terme c'est
d'une vision stratégique dont nous avons
besoin tel que celles présentées par le
Président de la République dans son
discours de Belfort en février dernier
cette stratégie repose sur le triptyque
sobriété nucléaire et renouvelable nous
ne pouvons qui souscrire mais lorsque
l'on regarde de plus en détail ce beau
tableau les choses se compliquent
singulièrement premièrement les
projections relatives à la qui était
nous semble irréaliste certes nous
pouvons renforcer nos efforts sur de
nombreux plans tels que l'isolation des
bâtiments ou l'autoconsommation mais 40%
de besoins énergétiques en moins en
200040 alors que nous serons un peu plus
nombreux et 20% plus riches si la
croissance moyenne n'est que de 1% d'ici
à cette date qui petit croire c'est
pourtant sur une telle anticipation que
repose la stratégie nationale bakarbonne
et tous les scénarios de RTE
en adoptant des hypothèses plus
réalistes ce sera déjà une très belle
performance d'arriver simplement à
maintenir et non augmenter nos besoins
énergétiques d'ici à 2040 mais dans ce
cas de figure ce n'est pas 60%
d'électricité en plus qu'il nous faudra
produire au tournant du siècle mais le
double ou le triple c'est bien pourquoi
les annonces faites jusqu'ici en matière
de nucléaire même si elles vont
incontestablement dans le bon sens nous
semble bien trop insuffisante à Belfort
le président de la République a déclaré
pour qu'un réacteur un état de produire
ne doit être fermé mais le plan de
fermeture de 12 réacteurs d'ici à 2035
est toujours en vigueur va t-il enfin
être officiellement abandonné dans
l'affirmative va-t-on prolonger nos
réacteurs au maximum c'est une question
clé car à construire en dépend de plus
aucun plan de développement de SMS n'a
été annoncé alors que le petit nucléaire
semble une solution d'avenir prometteuse
enfin la recherche est l'innovation dans
le nouveau nucléaire semblent relancer
mais à quelle fin précisément fermeture
du cycle du combustible réacteur de
quatrième génération au thorium il faut
un plan et des objectifs enfin pour ce
qui est des renouvelables je ne veux pas
ici empiéter sur les débats qui seront
les nôtres lors de l'examen du projet de
loi e NR mais je peux déjà dire que le
groupe de l'Union centrices plaidera en
faveur de l'essor de la grille voltaïsme
de la géothermie et de la biomasse plus
globalement chacun des trois volets du
plan français va se heurter un grave
problème de ressources humaines il faut
former dès maintenant de vrais
professionnels du nucléaire des réseaux
de l'isolation des bâtiments et des eénr
avons-nous un plan de formation digne de
ce nom pour faire face à ses besoins si
oui il nous faudra le connaître les
événements autant que le sens de
l'histoire nous invite à un Big Bang
énergétique alors montrons-nous à la
hauteur de ce rendez-vous je vous
remercie merci
chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Didier Rambaud pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre monsieur les ministres mes
chers collègues l'énergie
occupe une place dans le débat public
qu'elle a sans doute jamais eu
auparavant et pour cause guerre en
Ukraine contexte d'inflation tension
autour des carburants dérèglement
climatique autant de défis qui nous
rappelle que l'énergie abondante et à
bas prix n'existe plus préparer l'avenir
tout en apportant des réponses à
l'urgence c'est au fond madame la
Première ministre la double stratégie de
la France pour répondre à ces défis
majeurs d'une part à court terme pour
sauver notre approvisionnement d'autre
part à long terme pour assurer la
souveraineté énergétique de la France et
sa neutralité carbone pour ce qui est de
notre approvisionnement cela n'a échappé
à personne dans un contexte d'inflation
Poutine utilise l'énergie pour faire la
guerre nous faisons face comme nos
voisins européens à une situation
extrêmement délicate le gouvernement
fait donc le choix d'impulser une
nouvelle solidarité européenne
veut dire collectivement pour
s'entraider et s'alimenter en
électricité pour l'hiver agir avec
solidarité pour que nous évitions les
coupures en matière de gaz il était
décidé d'alimenter nos stocks auprès
d'autres fournisseurs nous permettant
ainsi de les remplir à hauteur de 99 %
par ailleurs le Parlement a voté en
juillet dernier l'accélération du projet
de terminale flottant au large du Havre
des décisions prises avec rapidité à la
hauteur de la crise géopolitique et qui
nous permettront de passer le prochain
hiver nous l'espérons avec le moins de
difficultés possible néanmoins soyons
lucides si l'approvisionnement de nos
stocks est nécessaire réaliser des
économies d'énergie n'en reste pas moins
indispensable et cela de manière
collective à commencer par l'État qui
doit être exemplaire sans oublier les
collectivités les entreprises et
l'ensemble des Français c'est tout
l'esprit du plan de sobriété que vous
avez présenté jeudi dernier madame la
Première ministre un plan qui prône
l'incitation et la responsabilité
objectifs pas de privation ni de textes
de loi tout simplement des gestes de bon
sens des gestes du quotidien que parfois
nos aïeux faisaient déjà se briété ne
signifie pas décroissance et tant que
nous pouvons saisissons l'option de la
sobriété choisie plutôt que d'attendre
la sobriété subie reconnaissant au
passage qu'il s'agit aussi d'une
opportunité pour lutter contre le
gaspillage énergétique et la
surconsommation le groupe RDPI se tient
totalement cette stratégie stratégique
qui ne doit pas nous faire perdre de vue
que face à l'urgence l'État doit aider
les acteurs les plus en difficulté je
rappelle que le gouvernement comme le
Parlement n'ont pas été inactif en la
matière pensons aux boucliers tarifaires
sur les prix de l'énergie qui sera
reconduit en 2023 pensons également aux
430 millions votés d'euros voter dans la
loi de finances rectificative en juillet
dernier à destination des collectivités
qui permettront à une part significative
du bloc communal d'avoir un peu d'air
après le quoi qu'il en coûte qui a
permis de sauver notre économie
désormais face à l'inflation les
Français les PME et les collectivités
resteront protégés c'est la promesse de
ce gouvernement toujours à l'offensive
pour conserver nos emplois et notre
pouvoir d'achat mes chers collègues
notre pays n'en reste pas moins
confronté à deux défis de taille assuré
la souveraineté énergétique et atteindre
la neutralité carbone d'ici 2050 rien ne
serait pire que de penser une fois
l'hiver passé que la crise énergétique
deviendrait un mauvais souvenir à
oublier les défis liés à l'énergie
seront au cœur des débats politiques des
années à venir renforcer notre
souveraineté c'est d'abord investir dans
le mixte énergétique prendre conscience
que l'éolien en mer le photovoltaïque la
grivevoltaïs et l'hydraulique sont
autant d'énergie renouvelables qu'il
nous faut développer en concertation
avec les élus locaux
renforcer notre souveraineté c'est aussi
admettre que le nucléaire doit prendre
toute sa part dans le mixte énergétique
aujourd'hui le nucléaire représente
environ 70% de la production électrique
française avec un modèle basé sur
l'électronucléaire il serait
déraisonnable de son passé les Allemands
ont souhaité faire ce choix et ils sont
aujourd'hui largement dépendant du gaz
bien entendu la part du nucléaire doit
être complémentaire avec celle des
énergies renouvelables mais le nucléaire
est une force historique nous devons la
conforter toujours est-il que notre parc
est vieillissant et requiert beaucoup de
maintenance on peut pas se satisfaire
que 26 réacteurs sur 56 soit
actuellement indisponible nous récoltons
aujourd'hui les fruits de mauvais
arbitrages passés la nationalisation des
DF est un mal nécessaire pour réarmer et
consolider notre ancien fleuron un
projet de loi sera justement présenté
dans les prochains mois pour simplifier
les procédures et permettre de faciliter
la création des nouvelles générations de
PR renforcer souveraineté c'est aussi
réduire les délais administratifs pour
accélérer sur les énergies renouvelables
là encore un projet de loi permettra en
novembre de débattre en profondeur de
ces questions mais regardons les choses
avec lucidité le tout nucléaire de
fonctionnera pas et le tout NR ne
fonctionnera pas davantage pour
atteindre nos objectifs nous devons
diversifier réduire les délais
administratives simplifier les
procédures libérer du foncier encourager
le partage territorial de la valeur
autant d'objectifs qui seront au cœur du
projet de loi d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables encore une fois
mon groupe sera au rendez-vous de ce
travail parlementaire renforcer notre
souveraineté exige également de se
réindustrialiser si l'objectif du plan
France 2030 avec 2 milliards d'euros
dédiés à l'innovation dans les énergies
renouvelables et nucléaires la France
peut se donner les moyens de construire
par exemple le premier avion bas carbone
mais la France peut également être en
mesure de réindus avec les énergies
décarbonées énergies telles que
l'hydrogène ou encore le gaz provenant
de déchets organiques mon département
l'Isère est un territoire à ce sujet qui
illustre bien la production de ce type
de gaz 9 sites à jettent injecte déjà du
biométhane dans les réseaux dont deux
sont en chantier et devraient en
injecter d'ici la fin de l'année enfin
notre souveraineté requiert une
solidarité européenne ne confondons pas
souveraineté et protectionnisme en
matière d'énergie nous devons penser en
Europe 1 l'histoire nous rappelle que
l'ancêtre de l'Union européenne était la
Communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier créé par 6 États en 1951 dont la
France il le fait aucun doute que les
mécanismes européens de tarification
doivent être réformés nous devrons
décorer les le prix de l'électricité du
prix du gaz les défis sont techniques et
complexes mais nous savons que le
gouvernement toute son énergie pour
convaincre nos voisins européens
Nietzsche pensait que l'Europe ne se
fera qu'au bord du tombeau le moment est
peut-être venu de créer une nouvelle
Union européenne énergétique mes chers
collègues les spécialistes les
ingénieurs les scientifiques nous
rappellent aussi une réalité de bon sens
l'énergie la plus propre et celle que
l'on ne consomme pas alors je ne prône
pas le retour à la bougie mais je suis
convaincu qu'en matière d'énergie comme
dans le milieu du sport notre boussole
doit être le collectif encourager le
collectif pour la mobilité encourager le
collectif en matière de choix
énergétiques encourager le collectif
enfin en matière de sobriété se dire que
si tout le monde s'y met avec esprit de
responsabilité et de solidarité l'État
les collectivités les entreprises et
nous tous en tant que citoyen nous nous
donnerons les moyens d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone d'ici 2050
merci chers collègues
ma parole est à notre collègue sabien
gay pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
vous avez la parole
sur le président madame la Première
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues nous vivons une période
critique décisive charnière l'urgence
est là pour notre économie pour les
entreprises les collectivités les
citoyennes et les citoyens la crise
énergétique que nous vivons est un défi
et elle va s'inscrire dans la durée la
situation nous oblige avec lucidité dans
une optique constructive nous devons
étudier comparer proposer et débattre
des moyens de notre politique et
souveraineté énergétique surtout nous
devons nous montrer capables d'une
vision d'ensemble nous ne résoudrons pas
cette crise énergétique en l'abordant
segment par segment comme vous nous le
proposez un texte cet été sur les
dérogations et ajustements puis un sur
les renouvelables qui va venir un autre
sur le nucléaire un autre qu'on apprend
sur l'hydroélectricité ce soir et enfin
une loi de programmation plus Ré celle
de l'énergie on ne sait quand et au
passage l'arrêtatisation d'EDF par
amendement au contraire nous avons
besoin d'une vision d'ensemble aux
risques de subir et de revivre
car ce que nous traversons aujourd'hui
cette envolée des prix ces menaces de
blackout ce n'est pas qu'un simple et
malheureux empilement des conjonctures
c'est l'obsolescence d'un système
énergétique tout entier qui entrain de
s'écrouler il y a une dimension
conjoncturelle c'est indéniable le
déclenchement de la gare en Ukraine bien
sûr puis en été digne d'un cataclysme
climatique lui aussi lourde conséquences
sur la production électrique les besoins
climatisation décuplés en Espagne et
avec eux la consommation énergétique du
pays des sécheresses Records comme vous
l'avez dit partout en Europe et des
pénuries d'eau inédites pour les
barrages français qui produisent 12% de
l'énergie du pays nous avons connu un
niveau d'eau historiquement bas le dans
un contexte de mise à l'arrêt de la
moitié du parc nucléaire dont une partie
n'était pas prévue une somme de facteurs
qui se conjugue et qui échappe à notre
emprise direct et immédiate mais ce que
nous maîtrisons et ce qui nous
appartient c'est la décision politique
et ce que nous voulons ce n'est pas un
état actionnaire qui gère comme le privé
mais un état volontariste et stratège
qu'à une vision d'avenir parce que
l'emballement des prix l'énergie que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui c'est un
résultat direct du marché européen de
l'énergie et de plus de 20 ans de
libéralisation du secteur lié le prix du
gaz et de l'électricité nous conduit à
cette situation où le prix payé par des
états et par les consommateurs ne
reflètent en rien le mix électrique
national quand le kilowatt-heure atteint
1000 euros comme il l'a fait cet été
nous ne parlons pas d'une réalité
matérielle mais des résultats
spéculatifs et artificiels les Français
les Européens ne peignent ni le prix de
l'énergie mais celui de l'Europe
libérale et des traders il suffit d'en
regarder le fonctionnement celui d'un
prix l'énergie commun à tous les États
membres les usagers paient le même prix
que leur pays investit dans le nucléaire
dans les renouvelables ou qu'ils soient
restés dépendant des énergies fossiles
faisant le bilan de ce mécanisme en
France seul 7,7% de la production
électrique dépend du gaz rien ne
justifie que les cours de l'électricité
dopées par les prix du gaz se
répercutent sur nous avec une telle
force allons chercher une sortie
temporaire du marché européen emboîtant
le pas de nos voisins espagnols et
portugais qui ont fait valoir que non
ils n'ont pas subir les cours du gaz qui
ne reflètent aucunement leur mix
énergétique d'ailleurs je suis très
heureux que vous disiez ce soir que vous
en êtes d'accord il faudra juste le dire
à votre secrétaire d'état chargé
d'Europe qui hier en audition devant la
commission européenne du Sénat à dit le
contraire
nous avons en France
92% de notre mix électrique
issu du nucléaire de l'hydraulique du
photovoltaïque du solaire et de l'éolien
92%. nous avons réduit nos importations
de gaz et notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles nous sommes donc légitimes à
porter cette demande sur la scène
européenne alors madame la Première
ministre je ne vous apprendrai rien en
vous disant que nous avons des débats
politiques mais je tiens à vous le dire
si vous décidez d'engager cette bataille
nous la mènerons à vos côtés
entendons-nous bien je ne parle pas
d'interope tout un interconnexion car il
faut garder de la solidarité européenne
il s'agit d'adorer former le système
européen en profondeur ou dans sortir
mais c'est un chantier qui prendra des
années nous pouvons donc obtenir une
dérogation dans les prochaines semaines
si nous nous battons car nous n'avons
pas des années pour agir les dégâts sont
déjà là d'abord pour nos collectivités
territoriales
les factures explosent 30% en moyenne
pour certaines nous en sommes à 150%.
dans mon département 2 millions d'euros
pour Noisy-le-Sec
idem pour Neuilly-sur-Marne et près de
30 millions pour le département des
arbitrages intenables sont des gens
préparation quel que soit nos couleurs
politiques augmenter les impôts locaux
renoncer à des investissements majeurs
comme la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments ou fermée des services publics
nous devons créer un bouclier tarifaire
réel immédiat à rétablissant les tarifs
réglementés de l'électricité pour toutes
les collectivités territoriales et
baisser la TVA à 5,5 pour tous les
usagers quant à la fin des tarifs
réglementés de vente du gaz en juillet
2023 c'est un grand danger dans la
période il faut empêcher coûte que coûte
cette extinction c'est une nécessité
absolue qui concerne aussi les
entreprises
électro-intensives avec l'inflation des
prix de l'énergie nous savons
pertinemment que vouloir sera la
variable d'ajustement des fermetures
sont déjà envisagées ou du chômage
partiel comme chez Duralex et Arc
International madame la Première
ministre je pose la question quel sera
le coup du chômage partiel pour l'État
sommes-nous vraiment dans un scénario
préférable au rétablissement des tarifs
réglementés pour tout le monde y compris
les artisans et commerçants comme les
boulangers car ce qui est sûr c'est que
les TRB sont préférables au bilan social
qui est à craindre nous allons traverser
au moins deux ans de crise et les prix
ne redescendront jamais enfin nous avons
12 millions de personnes qui sont en
situation de précarité énergétique
combien de plus vont basculer combien
d'impayés vont tomber il y a une urgence
sociale pour les deux prochaines années
il faut interdire les coupures de tous
les fournisseurs et pas que d'EDF et
garantir une puissance minimale à 3
kilowatts contre un aujourd'hui il faut
des actions fortes dans l'immédiat
couplées à une planification c'est un
impératif qui pose la question d'EDF
madame l'ami la première ministre je
salue l'organisation de ce débat
pardonnez-moi
merci mais je regrette que le Parlement
ne soit pas associé sur une question
aussi essentielle que la rue est
attisation de DF le débat est légitime
une réétapisation oui mais pourquoi
faire si c'est pour faire un projet
Hercule 2 qui viendra séparer les
activités et en ouvrir au chapitre privé
pour nous c'est non et sans attendre
2025 il faut sortir de la reine ce
système qui n'a fait qu'enrichir les
opérateurs alternatifs et dépece EDF car
si nous défendons un grand service
public de l'énergie avec monopole
publique c'est précisément parce que la
crise actuelle nous en offre une
démonstration le secteur privé et inapte
sur cette question d'autres crises nous
le prouverons dans les années à venir
nous devons investir des milliards
d'euros pour la sortie des énergies
fossiles il nous faut d'ailleurs
impérativement nous extraire de la
Charte européenne de l'énergie ce traité
de plein pouvoir multinationales qui
leur permettra de réclamer des milliards
à des états pour défendre leur
investissement dans les énergies
fossiles et maintenant caduques nous
défendons enfin le développement d'un
mix électrique avec des investissements
dans le nucléaire de nouvelles
générations et dans les énergies
renouvelables que pour notre part nous
nous posons pas nous avons besoin de
programmation de l'énergie réelle
concrète qui repose sur des indicateurs
fiables et avec une entreprise publique
solide qui a les capacités d'investir et
pour cela nous devons sortir l'énergie
du secteur marchand et en faire un bien
commun de toute l'humanité je vous
remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Franck
Menonville pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoire
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la Première ministre
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues entre le printemps 2020 et le
premier septembre 2022 les prix de
marché ont été multipliés par 3 pour le
pétrole 5 pour le gaz et 40 pour
l'électricité comment nous sommes
arrivés là
la reprise économique après le plus fort
de la pandémie a généré des tensions sur
les marchés avec le retour de
l'inflation le 24 février on envahissant
l'Ukraine va devenir Poutine a déclenché
un conflit entraînant entre autres une
flambée sans précédent des cours de
l'énergie en se servant ainsi du gaz
comme moyen de pression
l'Europe qui était dans un état de
dépendance vis-à-vis des hydrocarbures
russes est aujourd'hui dans une
situation difficile ce qui nous annonce
un hiver particulièrement compliqué il
faut le dire la France est
structurellement moins dépendante du gaz
russe que l'Allemagne et notamment qui a
renoncé au nucléaire la situation de la
France semblait meilleur en théorie
alors que le nucléaire était l'un des
atouts de la politique énergétique
française la moitié de nos 56 réacteurs
et la moitié de nos 56 réacteurs étant
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt pour des problèmes
de maintenance
cette année nous serons pour la première
fois importateur d'électricité parce que
nous avons pas su anticiper et préserver
notre parc
pour illustrer cela le 21 juillet 2022
rtea apporté en moyenne plus de 7000
mégawatts sur le marché spot européen
soit 15% de la consommation nationale
une certaine idée de l'écologie peut
poussait donc pour la réduction voir la
disparition du nucléaire aujourd'hui
notre filière va mal et mal en point et
fragilisé nous devons tout faire pour
conserver nos savoir-faire et garantir
son avenir à Saint-Nazaire le 22
septembre dernier le président Macron a
esquissé alors que nous sommes au pied
du mur l'accélération de la stratégie
nucléaire de la France
il y a 30 ans
encore nous étions les champions du
monde de l'énergie nucléaire civile nous
disposions d'une autonomie et nous
exportions même notre excédent
électrique nous avons baissé la garde en
menant des politiques contradictoires
guidées par des choix idéologiques mon
son mon compte souvent de réalisme je
pourrais citer Ségolène Royal qui
souhaitaient baisser de 75% à 50% la
part du nucléaire à horizon 2025 une
orfèvre en matière de géopolitique et de
planification énergétique
ne devrions-nous pas madame la Première
ministre réviser cet objectif qui
subsiste encore dans la loi à horizon
2035 nous sommes bientôt en 2023 alors
même que nous le savons les besoins
d'électricité seront croissants
à la longue liste qui nous conduit à la
situation actuelle on peut ajouter
l'abandon du projet de centrale super
Phénix de traitement des déchets
nucléaires en 1997 le projet Astrid
portant pourtant lancer en 2010
abandonné en 2019 sans programme de
recherche alternatif fermant ainsi la
porte à de nouvelles avancées
technologiques la décision de fermeture
de Fessenheim prise sur la présidence de
François Hollande nous obligeons
aujourd'hui dans notre région Grand Est
à réouvrir une centrale à charbon je ne
parle pas de l'affaiblissement continue
des capacités financières d'EDF
notamment fragilisé par la reine et qui
ne peuvent
qu'ils ne seront pas exclusivement
réglés par la nationalisation c'est
autant de d'injonctions contradictoires
qui ont contribué à fragiliser à
fragiliser cette filière d'excellence
française la structuration même des
portefeuilles ministériels antérieurs
ne sont sans doute pas étrangers à cela
il me semble que les précédents grands
ministères de l'écologie et du
développement durable n'avait pas
naturellement dans leur ADN la capacité
de planification
énergétique et industrielle nous sentons
beaucoup de la constitution de ce
nouveau ministère de la transition
énergétique qui semble aller dans le bon
sens notre pays a besoin d'un grand
ministère de l'Énergie et de l'industrie
par ailleurs force est de constater
qu'on a affaibli dans notre pays le dans
notre pays donc le pilier du nucléaire
sans pour autant atteindre les objectifs
que nous sommes fixés dans la PPE en
matière de développement d'énergie
renouvelable en effet les complexité
administratives rendent le déploiement
des ENR
difficile et beaucoup trop long sur par
rapport à nos voisins européens notre
bouquet énergétique a besoin tant du
nucléaire que des énergies renouvelables
les projets de loi qui sont que vous
avez annoncé aujourd'hui doivent
absolument pouvoir devoir y répondre il
faut il faut travailler sur tous ces
leviers il n'est pas acceptable
d'attendre plus de 10 ans pour voir
naître un projet éolien ou solaire
porter et voulu par les territoires et
sur nos territoires
pratiquement le double des pays
européens qui nous entourent la crise à
laquelle nous devons faire face en
cependant criant le besoin d'un
changement structurel de notre politique
énergétique française notre économie est
déjà touchée par la crise économique il
faut bien sûrveiller à ne pas fragiliser
davantage notre issue économique dans le
cadre d'un éventuel délestage il faudra
absolument être en mesure de protéger et
de prioriser la capacité productive
actuellement forcer de constater qu'en
France de plus en plus d'usines tourner
au ralenti à cause des prix de l'énergie
nous sommes sur nos territoires tous
alerté sur la situation complexe voire
intenable dans le temps en matière
d'industrie d'artisanat et quelquefois
d'accès d'agriculture également beaucoup
de nos chaînes de valeur sont mises en
péril par des importations plus
compétitives la crise énergétique est en
train de porter un coup dur à notre
industrie au moment où
mouvement donc nécessaire de
réindustrialisation dans la France a
besoin nos collectivités territoriales
nos entreprises ainsi que les ménages
français déjà fortement affectés
subissent d'ores et déjà les
conséquences économiques de cette crise
énergétique les inquiétudes qui nous
remontent du terrain sont grandissante
la France a mis beaucoup de amis bien en
place donc un bouclier tarifaire afin
d'aider donc les ménages à faire face à
l'envoler des prix de l'énergie ces
mesures nécessaires ont un coût et sont
un coût important et pourtant elle
demeure incomplète au regard des
disparités des situations rencontrées
sur le terrain
l'Europe doit au plus vite trouver des
solutions il faut penser différemment la
politique énergétique européenne et plus
précisément le marché intérieur européen
de l'énergie nous devons découpler donc
découpler le prix de l'électricité de
celui du gaz vous l'avez annoncé pour
conclure nous devons bâtir une véritable
stratégie de long terme elle ne peut
être dissociée d'une de la question
industrielle l'énergie est au cœur donc
de notre économie en conclusion notre
politique énergétique doit reposer sur
trois piliers premièrement une
optimisation et la promotion d'économie
d'énergie reposant sur la recherche le
développement des technologies économe
sur la rénovation énergétique
deuxièmement le développement autant que
possible des énergies renouvelables et
troisièmement la relance du nucléaire
autant que nécessaire en accentuant nos
savoir-faire technologiques mes chers
collègues il n'y a pas de place pour
l'idéologie le dogmatisme nous devons
porter une vision de long terme
répondant aux besoins de notre demande
d'électricité des carbonée et ainsi vers
aller vers la sortie programmée des
énergies fossiles merci mon cher
collègue donnez la parole maintenant à
notre collègue Jean-Pierre cormicelle
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
la parole monsieur le Président Madame
la première ministre monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
gouvernement a présenté la semaine
dernière son plan de sobriété on peut se
féliciter de cette encouragement même
tardif à la sobriété mais Laurent encore
fallu une situation de crise et une
urgence tant économique que sociale pour
que l'État presse le pas nous n'aurions
sans doute pas pu éviter la crise mais
ses effets auraient été moins explosifs
la réduction de la consommation
énergétique de 40% d'ici 2050 pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone se fera
désormais sur une trajectoire de la dont
la pente sera bien raide nous sommes là
pour débattre pour partager des constats
mais aussi réfléchir à des solutions
pour éviter que cette désastre situation
ne se reproduise
abordons donc la question de manière
ascendante comme l'aurait dit mon
collègue Fabien gay la situation de nos
concitoyens tout d'abord
malgré les multiples demandés alertes
des acteurs locaux qu'ils soient publics
ou associatifs en dépit des annonces
successives d'un grand plan national de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
forcer de constater que le compte n'y
est pas
issu d'un département où les
températures ne sont pas toujours
clémentes et où l'habitat individuelle
notamment minier compte parmi les moins
bien isolés malgré un gros rattrapage
ces dernières années je peux mesurer au
quotidien combien il reste à faire et
pour les habitants concernés c'est la
double peine nous savons que ceux qui
sont dans les habitations les plus
énergivores sont également ceux qui
vivent des situations économiques et
sociales parmi les plus dramatiques il
suffit de parcourir les documents de
bilan des dossiers des fonciers de
vérité logement pour s'apercevoir du
niveau de précarité de fragilité de
nombreux ménages
le chèque énergie constitue sa tunnels
mais elle ne peut agir que comme un
pansement face aux perspectives
d'augmentation des tarifs qu'on nous
annonce et la baisse progressive du
bouclier tarifaire j'ai déjà interpellé
l'État à plusieurs reprises sur la
question du reste à charge des aides
proposées par la norme il reste
dissuasif pour un trop grand nombre de
nos concitoyens c'est le même problème
que pour le coup de l'essence les
personnes modestes ont souvent des
véhicules anciens plus consommateurs que
de carburant là encore j'ai contesté en
100 ans quand j'étais le rapporteur sur
le bonus malus madame la ministre à
l'époque de la suppression du dispositif
d'accompagnement financier à chaque
véhicule hybride et de sa limitation à
l'achat de voiture électrique dont les
tarifs même avec une aide reste
probabilités pour beaucoup regarder
l'explosion du prix de la Zoé il nous
faut là aussi réfléchir désormais un
vaste plan de conversion notre parc
automobile est d'accompagnement des
ménages les plus modestes à
l'acquisition de véhicules plus propres
deuxièmement la situation de nos
collectivités maintenant
j'ai interrogé la semaine dernière votre
ministre de la transition écologique de
la cohésion des territoires sur
l'augmentation alarmante des coûts de
l'énergie pour nos collectivités et
l'inquiétude des élus face à cette
situation
insuffisance prévisible de l'enveloppe
ouverte en loi de finance rectificative
imprécision quant aux modalités de
mobilisation se font il adaptation des
critères repoussant l'obtention des
fonds au mieux à l'été 2023 sur toutes
ces questions le ministre a évolue
rassurant ils a promis des réponses
rapides espérons-le mais surtout ces
réponses devront être adaptées et ne pas
être soumises à des critères trop
restrictifs désormais seul 8000 communes
au lieu de 20000 semblent pouvoir
prétendre à l'enveloppe des 430 millions
d'euros
dernièrement une nouvelle explicative
adressée en fin de semaine dernière par
le secrétariat de Monsieur Attal fait
état de trois critères cumulatifs à
remplir en complexifie on renforce au
final ce sont peut-être encore moins de
communes qui pourront émerger à ce
dispositif
[Musique]
et sur le fond illusoire vraiment songé
de laisser penser que cette accélération
des ENR serait la solution à nos
difficultés le recours aux énergies
naturelles ne pourront en aucun cas être
une solution à la demande d'énergie
puisque elles sont pas nature
intermittentes
en outre il est dommage que le texte
fasse l'impasse sur un point important
celui de la constitution de véritables
filières du renouvelable actez le
principe d'une accélération de synergies
renouvelables est une chose mais créer
les conditions de sa réussite
nécessitent de sécuriser toute la chaîne
afin de la pérenniser d'autant plus que
l'éolien est aujourd'hui recyclable à
plus de 97%. une faute garantir un
soutien financier durable et prévisible
de l'État assurer une politique de
formation efficiente travail à
l'attractivité de ces filières lutter
efficacement contre les malfaçons avec
une politique de label
autant au sein du RDSE nous nous
saisirons ce texte par nous sommes parce
que nous sommes conscients de l'urgence
mais en tentant d'en corriger les excès
et pour y introduire des améliorations
considèrent le développement de ces
énergies renouvelables et la
préservation de la nature
les sujets sont techniques complexes en
matière d'énergie je pense à
l'hydroélectricité absorbe du projet de
loi sur l'accélération des ENR je pense
aussi à l'agrivoltaïsme je pense enfin
la filière du biogaz et au gaz vert elle
aussi grande oubliée du projet de loi
sur les EnR ce matin même la première
musique je posais à Arras la première
pierre de rats centre de méthanisation
des déchets ménagers de la communauté
urbaine d'Arras et je ne comprenais pas
que les bouts de la station d'impuration
à côté ne pouvait pas être méthanisé
alors qu'en Allemagne les bouts de
station de dépuration sont méthanisables
le plus de 15 ans toute les pistes
doivent être étudiées et l'ensemble des
acteurs écoutés si on veut atteindre les
objectifs fixés dans les déclarations du
président de la République à Belfort est
repris dans le plan sobriété je reste
convaincu que la solution réside dans le
dans la diversité du mix énergétique
l'occasion de soulever un autre
incohérence à mon sens pourquoi
mobiliser un projet de loi différent sur
le volet nucléaire de notre
approvisionnement énergétique il nous
faut travailler dans l'articulation des
modes de production il aurait été plus
logique de traiter la question
énergétique dans un seul et même texte
après avoir discuté de la programmation
pluriannuelle énergétique comme l'a dit
le président rotaïeu tout à l'heure
projeté un développement du parc
nucléaire est une chose une somme ici
sur du moyen voire du long terme sur
tout si l'on se réfère aux douloureuses
épisodes du premier repère assurer le
redémarrage de la moitié de notre parc
aujourd'hui maintenant en est une autre
madame ministre vous nous avez donné les
assurances et pour nous réellement
compter sur ce renforcement avant
l'hiver la rue nationalisation d'EDF
représente aussi une opportunité pour
reprendre en main notre avenir
industriel et roulant celui nucléaire
mais à quelle échéance et à quel prix
s'accompagnera-t-elle d'un retour au
tarifs réglementé pour les collectivités
si la France ainsi que d'autres États
membres ont pris position faveur de la
découplage entre le prix de
l'électricité sud du gaz la réforme du
marché européen de l'électricité
pourrait-elle être mise en place avant
que les conséquences sur nos entreprises
et nous constituons se désastreuses je
vous remercie merci mon chers collègues
donner la parole notre collègue Daniel
seulement pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mais chers collègues en
septembre 2021 déjà 12 millions de
Français ne pouvaient pas se chauffer
comme il le souhaitait un an après à
l'approche de l'hiver l'Europe traverse
une crise économique et géopolitique qui
met en lumière les lacunes systémiques
de nos sociétés en matière
d'approvisionnement énergétique cette
crise questionne en profondeur notre
modèle de consommation et valide ne vous
en déplaise le projet que les
écologistes portent depuis des années
les stratégies à mettre en place pour
sortir des énergies fossiles atteindre
la neutralité carbone en 2050 et ainsi
respecter les objectifs de l'accord de
Paris sont plus que jamais attendus et
urgentes elles doivent être à la hauteur
des enjeux historiques
l'abondance énergétique a une fin nous
le savons depuis des décennies notre
développement assise sur l'extractivisme
se heurte à la finitude de la planète et
à la saturation de son atmosphère en
polluant
aujourd'hui en matière de politique
énergétique pour respecter nos
engagements climatiques différentes
options sont sur la table
au préalable je voudrais réaffirmer
qu'il n'y a pas de production d'énergie
parfaitement propres excepté celle que
l'on ne consomme pas et j'y reviendrai
concernant la production la seule option
qui permette une transition soutenable
et durable est un mix énergétique que
nous appelons de nos vœux et qui n'a pas
changé nous défendons le déploiement
massif de nos énergies renouvelables
vers le 100% en 2050 et en parallèle la
sortie programmée du nucléaire nous
reverliendrons sur le sujet en fin
d'année oui une France 100% renouvelable
en 2050 et techniquement possible sans
mettre en péril la sécurité
d'approvisionnement comme le souligne
l'un des scénarios de RTE scénario
totalement crédible comme le rappelle
son président nous devons y aller parce
que c'est l'énergie la plus propre la
plus sûre la plus résiliente et la moins
chère vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Première ministre cette énergie est
aujourd'hui extrêmement compétitive et
rentable nous aurons l'occasion de
défendre ce déploiement massif et
indispensable dans les futurs véhicules
législatifs mais en attendant les
retards pris pour engager la France sur
les rails de la transition énergétique
et l'absence d'anticipation des
gouvernements successifs sont
particulièrement graves ils sont la
cause de notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles ainsi que de la crise sociale
profonde qui en découle que de temps
perdu les énergies renouvelables ce sont
les énergies des territoires les grands
projets comme les plus petits comme
l'illustre les centaines d'initiatives
partout en France les habitants et les
élus locaux souhaitent prendre leur
responsabilités face aux crises ils
souhaitent aussi créer des circuits
courts de l'énergie et de nouvelles
solidarités locales c'est pourquoi les
politiques publiques doivent renforcer
la concertation l'implication
l'investissement des habitants et des
collectivités locales dans les projets
la dynamique de l'énergie citoyenne est
un rouage essentiel de l'essor des
renouvelables à condition de changer de
braquet dans les modes de soutien qui
lui sont consacrés donnez également
davantage de moyens aux collectivités
locales dans la mise en oeuvre de la
transition écologique est indispensable
et doit aller bien au-delà du fond
climat que vous dotez de 2 milliards
rappelons que les collectivités
territoriales compétentes PCI région se
sont vus transférer de nouvelles
compétences sans aucun transfert de
moyens par conséquent les plans et
schémas en faveur de la transition
énergétique ne pourront être mis en
oeuvre et risque de rester en grande
partie à l'état d'attention
au-delà du financement l'action des
collectivités implique également de
développer des moyens d'ingénierie dans
les territoires et d'accompagner le
secteur privé avançons pour structurer
réellement cette mise en mouvement
généralisée des territoires en faveur de
la transition énergétique c'est tout le
sens du service public des énergies
renouvelables que nous défendons depuis
longtemps avec le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire service public qui
permettrait de planifier les politiques
publiques en la matière
permettez-moi en fin d'accès mon propos
sur un autre sujet majeur de notre
indispensable transition la
planification de la sobriété c'est le
seul moyen de réguler notre consommation
afin de respecter les limites
planétaires tout en réduisant les
inégalités qu'on soit clair la sobriété
ce n'est pas un slogan temporaire pour
passer l'hiver c'est le principe
d'organisation économique et sociale
nécessaire pour respecter l'accord de
Paris et sauvegarder pour l'indicte
l'espèce humaine
parce que la sobriété sans égalité c'est
l'austérité pour les plus pauvres nous
défendons une sobriété juste
près de deux ans après avoir raillé le
modèle Amish le gouvernement a
finalement dû se résoudre à l'évidence
en s'engageant dans un plan de sobriété
mais sans réelle contrainte sur le
secteur privé y compris sur les plus
gros polvleurs sans mesure pérenne ni
structurante ce plan n'est clairement
pas à la hauteur des enjeux une série de
petites mesures de bon sens mais au bon
vouloir de chacun comme d'habitude
madame la Première ministre vous n'allez
vous n'avez même pas regardé la première
des mesures contraignantes qui figurait
dans le programme du président candidat
puis dans votre déclaration de politique
générale rendre obligatoire l'indexation
de la rémunération des dirigeants des
grandes entreprises sur le respect de
leurs objectifs environnementaux nous
sommes encore bien loin de la
planification écologique promise pendant
la campagne présidentielle
j'ajouterai qu'il n'y a pas de solution
à la crise énergétique que nous ne
connaissions sans lutte contre les
injustices et sans remise en cause des
privilèges de certains alors que tant
d'entre nous subissent déjà au quotidien
une sobriété contrainte que les
comportements les comportements et
pratiques de consommation des plus
riches ne soient pas régulées et cadrées
est injuste et
inefficace
rappelons qu'aujourd'hui les disparités
en matière d'émission de carbone sont
colossales
quand Monsieur Bernard Arnault prend son
jet privé et aimait 176 tonnes de
dioxyde de carbone en un mois soit
l'équivalent de 17 ans d'empreinte
carbone d'un Français moyen oui le déni
de justice est là vertigineux
sans recherche d'une répartition juste
des efforts accomplir toute politique ou
recommandations de sobriété énergétiques
sera vécue comme une forme d'austérité
contraignante et injuste par les plus
pauvres et précaires ce plan manque donc
sa cible
et alors qu'on compte plus de 5 millions
de passoires thermiques impossible à
chauffer l'hiver et rafraîchir l'été ce
plan ne prévoit que 100 millions d'euros
de plus pour financer ma prime rénoble
soit à peine 4% d'augmentation moins que
l'inflation des coûts de des coups de
l'isolation et ce alors que ce
dispositif dysfonctionne n'est pas assez
doté ni suffisamment efficace ce rapport
fait donc l'impasse sur l'essentiel
stopper les productions superflues
réduire les inégalités financer les
services publics et l'isolation des
logements il ne reprend en rien la force
subversive et politique de ce concept de
sobriété et reste aveugle à la nécessité
d'un changement de paradigme concernant
nos modes de consommation
pourtant la sobriété est compatible avec
le bien-être et même susceptible de
l'accroître plutôt qu'une perte de
confort la transition vers une sobriété
juste assurera les besoins fondamentaux
se loger se nourrir se déplacer dans une
meilleure équité sociale le respect que
nous devons aux générations futures et
l'indispensable prise en compte du
vivant sur la terre
en conclusion la politique énergétique
que nous défendons c'est le droit à
l'énergie pas au gaspillage que chacune
et chacun est accès à une énergie
abordable aujourd'hui et demain à une
énergie qui ne nuise ni aux écosystèmes
ni à la santé les mesures à prendre
d'urgence pour passer l'hiver sont en
réalité les mêmes que celles qui doivent
nous permettre de préserver une planète
vivable et faire durablement baisser le
prix de l'énergie réduire et partager
produire l'indispensable voilà la
philosophie des écologistes discutons
planifions repolitisons ce qui doit être
avant tout un choix de société
madame la Première ministre vous ne vous
êtes engagé tout de suite à reconstruire
une filière photovoltaïque dépêchez-vous
car Photowatt détenu par EDF est en
train de mourir il est grand temps de
remettre en place des filières dans
l'énergie renouvelable en France vu le
fiasco de la filière nucléaire nous ne
pouvons que faire mieux merci
merci la parole
va être
pour 3 minutes
sur Stéphane Ravier pour la Réunion
administrative des sénateurs ne figurant
sur la liste d'aucun groupe vous savez
la parole
allez le meilleur pour la fin pour vous
réveiller mes chers collègues
avec ceux qui nous ont entraînés dans
cette folie ce dont vous êtes
responsable c'est de continuer à nous
imposer ces énergies prétendument
renouvelables contre la démocratie
locale par une circulaire de septembre
dernier vous exigez des préfets qu'ils
cassent les PLU dans lesquels les
communes mentionneraient l'interdiction
d'implanter les éoliennes de plus vous
préférez limoger le PDG d'EDF après
qu'il ait pointé vos responsabilités
dans la situation actuelle le limoge
devenant une véritable méthode de
gouvernement c'est pourtant EDF qui a
racheté au printemps dernier les
turbines nucléaires dolstom vendus en
2014 à l'Américain général électrique
par un certain Emmanuel Macron ce n'est
pas Jean-Bernard Lévy qui a procédé à la
fermeture idéologique et injustifiée
dans la centrale nucléaire de Fessenheim
c'est vous et vous en étiez fier en
France on n'a pas de gaz mais on a des
idées la sobriété et le col roulé vous
venez de déclarer vouloir sortir des
énergies fossiles mais vous avez
réouvert cet été la centrale à charbon
de Saint-Avold vieille de 71 ans
l'abandon de notre souveraineté
énergétique nous a rendu tributaire de
l'étranger c'est pourquoi en voulant
sanctionner Vladimir Poutine votre
Europe c'est déshonoré en signant des
accords gasiés avec l'Azerbaïdjan
finançant ainsi par nos impôts la guerre
menée contre l'Arménie il faut le dire
et le répéter le nucléaire et notre
force économique et écologique
contrairement à l'éolien qui saccage nos
paysages pour une production énergétique
dérisoire et au solaire qui sont toutes
deux des énergies intermittentes
nécessairement couplée au central à gaz
et à charbon le grand carénage en cours
est un grand plan de modernisation de la
filière nucléaire avec les EPR pour le
pour le moment victime d'un
sous-investissement chronique le
nucléaire représente l'avenir un avenir
d'indépendance énergétique il ne faut
pas non plus oublier de protéger notre
filière hydroélectrique décarbonée
actuellement menacé de libéralisation et
ne manque d'entretien madame la Première
ministre vous êtes dans le domaine
énergétique qui n'est pas question de
croyance mais de pragmatisme et de
réalité je rappelle que la France n'est
responsable que de 1% des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre à l'origine du
réchauffement climatique je vous invite
donc à vous dépolluer l'esprit des
prêches des talibans verdoyants et
attirer les enseignements de vos erreurs
plutôt que d'en faire supporter les
conséquences aux Français merci
je l'excuse pour répondre aux orateurs
monsieur le ministre
ce ministre délégué en charge de
l'Industrie de la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs la première ministre
merci pour ce débat qui dans l'ensemble
a traité je pense de l'essentiel c'est à
dire de l'avenir de l'avenir de nos
filières industriels de l'avenir de
notre production énergétique de l'avenir
au fond de la souveraineté française et
dans des plaises à Monsieur ravier
également de la souveraineté européenne
mais j'ai quand même entendu ici ou là
quelques critiques sur le bilan quelques
critiques sur la politique nucléaire de
la France y compris quelques critiques
causés sur le bilan du gouvernement
précédent et de notre président de la
République et donc je souhaite puisque
on se souhaite ensemble faire le bilan
du nucléaire prendre un peu de recul et
revenir à la réalité de ce qui est
aujourd'hui l'état des centrales
nucléaires en France et de leur histoire
la réalité ça a été dit un certain
nombre de fois sur tous les bancs c'est
que pour faire durer les centrales
nucléaires il faut les entretenir
et la réalité aussi c'est que des
investissements massifs dans les
centrales nucléaires
qui expliquent sans doute une grande
partie de la situation d'aujourd'hui
c'est au début des années 2000 qu'elle a
eu lieu on n'a jamais autant désinvestis
dans les centrales nucléaires françaises
que sous les quinquennats de Jacques
Chirac et Nicolas Sarkozy
et c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est la
Cour des comptes dans un rapport de 2012
et à l'époque vous le savez sans doute
puisque vous avez lu le rapport de la
Cour des comptes comme moi
la disponibilité des centrales s'est
effondrée entre 2005 et 2009
ensuite vous le savez aussi le choc pour
le nucléaire ça a été l'accident de
Fukushima en 2011 qui a conduit
l'ensemble des États à revoir leur
politique nucléaire le Japon bien sûr
le Japon bien sûr
la Belgique qui revient sur sa politique
de l'époque l'Allemagne qui n'en est pas
revenu et qui a fermé la plupart de ces
centrales je pense qu'il ne reste que
trois aujourd'hui sur les 35 initiales
et même la France à l'époque s'est
interrogée je vous rappelle que le
président Nicolas Sarkozy a décidé
d'abandonner le projet de père de Penly
en 2011
et je le comprends suite suite à
l'accident j'ai compris que certains
voulaient tuer le père moi je fais le
bilan de la politique énergétique de la
France monsieur le sénateur
plus sérieusement plus sérieusement
11 ans après l'accident de Fukushima
la France avait 58 réacteurs nous en
avons aujourd'hui 56 Winx en avons fermé
deux mais aujourd'hui la France est un
des seuls grands pays industrialisés qui
a gardé le cap sur le nucléaire et ça au
fond on doit peut-être à l'ensemble des
gouvernements qui ont tenu le choc
malgré des sous-investissements malgré
malgré un accident historique et qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on a cette base qui
nous permet d'investir encore davantage
la réalité la réalité c'est que le
ministre de l'économie
Emmanuel Macron c'est lui qui a sauvé
Framatome la réalité c'est que le
ministre de l'économie c'est lui qui a
sauvé Areva la réalité c'est que le
ministre de l'Économie Emmanuel Macron
c'est lui qui a recapitalisé EDF qui
avait été trop longtemps sous
capitaliser la réalité c'est que le
Président de la République dès qu'il est
arrivé il a revu l'objectif de 50% de
nucléaire pour 2025 pour le repousser de
10 ans à horizon 2035 la réalité c'est
que quand nous avons protégé les
Français vous allez français avec le
bouclier énergétique la réalité c'est
que nous avons aussi protégé EDF et que
nous avons pris sur le dernier public le
poids de cette protection
la réalité c'est que c'est le président
de la République aujourd'hui vous l'avez
dit à de Belfort en janvier de cette
année qui a annonçait la création la
construction pardon de 6 EPR et l'étude
monsieur Gremillet de 8 EPR
supplémentaires 6 + 8 si je ne m'abuse
ça fait 14 on nous a reproché de ne pas
en faire 14 nous en construisons 6 et
nous antillions 8 de plus ce qui m'amène
à parler de notre projet pour EDF
puisque maintenant on peut se projeter
vers l'avenir le bilan j'espère étant en
partie soldé
parler de ce projet de la reprise de DF
de la renationalisation d'EDF qui a été
annoncée qui va de mise en oeuvre d'ici
la fin de l'année
la réalité c'est qu'il ne s'agit en
aucun cas d'un aimant tellement def je
pense qu'on a jamais évoqué cette
possibilité
la réalité c'est une reprise en main
industrielle et opérationnelle de notre
opérateur national la présidente prima
s'en souvient sans doute nous étions
ensemble en juin 2018 pour visiter le
père de Flamanville le président Hervé
Moret était là également la présidente
barbara Pompili nous étions avec le
ministre Sébastien Lecornu et on nous a
expliqué à l'époque que le père de
Flamanville commencerait à produire ses
premiers électrons en janvier 2019 oui
la réalité c'est que perf femme envie
c'est une déception énorme il a été
lancé en 2000 les gouvernements
successifs l'ont allez confirmer
certains du bout des lèvres d'autres
avec plus d'ambition et qu'on n'a pas
réussi et je le regrette à livrer la
marchandise la réalité aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a besoin de reprendre en main avec
une direction opérationnelle les
opérations industrielles et
opérationnelles de notre grand
national un fin ensemble nous puissions
à nouveau en être fier on nationalise
EDF pour lever un financement à bas coût
et pour financer les projets de nouveaux
nucléaires on nationalise pour mettre en
place une casier régie qui permettra
l'état de garder les barrages je sais
que vous êtes sensibles et de réinvestir
dans ces barrages on veut qu'on DF
continue à investir durablement et plus
massivement dans les EnR la réalité
c'est que nous souhaitons développer EDF
de manière ambitieuse de manière à ce
que la souveraineté économique la
souveraineté électrique de la France
soit assuré
au-delà d'EDF j'ai entendu pas mal de
questions et quelques critiques sur le
fait qu'on mettrait la charrue avant les
bœufs en parlant de Saint-Arnoult
et déterminés avant de parler de la PPE
qu'est-ce qu'on nous aurait dit si on
n'avait passé l'été ici et à l'Assemblée
à parler de programmation pureuelle de
l'énergie à horizon des années 24 et 29
alors que la vraie inquiétude qu'on
avait tous à l'époque c'est est-ce qu'on
aura du gaz à l'hiver la réalité
effectivement c'est que du fait de
l'invasion d'un pays souverain par la
Russie nous nous retrouvons face à une
crise énergétique que nous devons gérer
et la première réponse à cette crise
énergétique et oui c'était d'assuré
qu'on est suffisamment de gaz en Europe
suffisamment d'énergie en Europe pour
répondre aux risques de rationnement que
personne je pense sur aucun de ses bancs
ne souhaite voir arriver
alors la PPE elle viendra elle est
prévue et elle aura une ambition vous le
savez
à la fois de développer de manière
ambitieuse le nucléaire
et le renouvelable dans des plaises à
Monsieur salmon sénateur il faut des
deux sauf dans un scénario un peu
extrême de RTE nous préférons les
scénarios centraux qui de manière
ambitieuse équilibrée ça a été dit sur
tous les bancs doivent développer à la
fois du nucléaire d'aujourd'hui et de
demain et des énergies renouvelables à
la fois de l'hydraulique la première
ministre la râpé d'ancien intervention
liminaire de la grivoltaïsme vous l'avez
dit aussi madame la Première ministre en
cohérence avec les vœux et les
déshydratas du Sénat et pourquoi pas la
géothermie je pense que ça a été
mentionné ici également en bref nous
sommes à l'offensive le scénar le
sénateur panorambeau l'a dit nous sommes
à l'offensive pour développer une
politique énergique ambitieuse qui
permettra à la France
de développer de manière durable son
industrie j'y reviendrai en conclusion
deux points pour terminer d'abord les
questions qui ont été posées sur ces
bancs sur le soutien au marché sur le
soutien aux entreprises et sur le
soutien aux collectivités locales du
fait de la crise en Ukraine et la crise
énergétique qui en découle
beaucoup d'entre vous certains d'entre
vous ont demandé à ce qu'on supprime la
reine
j'espère que vous plaisantez le ministre
de l'Industrie que je suis vous dit
monsieur le sénateur gay que si on
supprime l'arène demain vous mettez
toute l'industrie française à genoux à
l'arrêt aujourd'hui vous avez demandé
beaucoup d'entre vous à sortir du marché
européen la réalité c'est qu'on est en
partie sortie du marché européen grâce à
la reine et qu'aujourd'hui les ménages
français payent une électricité qui est
en dessous peut-être pas le dire trop
fort de du tarif européen de marché et
que les industriels français aujourd'hui
s'ils sont pas tous à l'arrêt c'est
qu'une partie de l'énergie oui et payer
un tarif préférentiel qui reflète
l'avantage concurrentiel d'EDF soyons en
tous fiers et réfléchissons plutôt
ensemble à la manière d'inventer le
dispositif qui au-delà de la reine
puisque celle-ci sera terminée en 2023
2024 permettra l'industrie française de
continuer à profiter d'une énergie
compétitive des carbonée produite par
notre opérateur national
vraiment la reine merci la reine d'abord
et continuons la reine s'il vous plaît
demandez à tous les industriels monsieur
le sénateur gay tous les industriels
aujourd'hui heureusement qu'on a la
reine sinon on serait mort
la solidarité
alors il va falloir changer la
tarification vous avez eu raison
monsieur le sénateur de Retailleau il va
falloir mettre en place un découplage du
gaz l'électricité il va falloir on
laisse permettre en place un scénario à
l'espagnol si on l'avait mis en place au
moment où vous le souhaitiez monsieur
Retailleau vous savez bien qu'on aurait
subventionné
toute l'électricité allemande et que la
seule manière de faire de la solidarité
nationale madame la sénatrice simple et
nous l'a dit c'est de le faire en
européen et là encore dans des prises
dans des plaises au sénateur-réviés de
le faire à l'européenne nous gagnerons
cette lutte en européen où nous là
perdons
son soutien collectivité locale monsieur
sénateur vous avez raison de nous
alerter la première ministre a déjà
évoqué nous travaillons à des situations
un certain nombre à des solutions pardon
un certain nombre ont déjà été annoncés
une hausse de la dotation générale de
fonctionnement de 110 millions en plus
pour 2023 un filet de sécurité qui
permettra d'aider les collectivités
locales qui sont le plus en difficulté
bref nous travaillons maintenant elles
ne sont pas toutes en difficulté madame
la sénatrice aujourd'hui pour les
industries comme pour les collectivités
territoriales nous devons faire du
ciblage un dernier point et j'en arrête
là les filières industrielles nous
devons développer une énergie souveraine
nous devons produire en France
ce qui va nous permettre de la produire
nous devons redévelopper des filières
industrielles ça a été dit par un
certain nombre d'entre vous dans le
photovoltaïque dans le nucléaire
évidemment mais aussi dans l'éolien et
pour cela vous le savez nous
investissons France 2030 qui fête
aujourd'hui madame la Première ministre
c'est un an c'est exactement ça investir
dans l'innovation de manière à ce qu'on
puisse développer des filières
françaises deux décarbonations de
l'industrie et de l'industrie des
carbonée je suis extrêmement fier de
participer à cette mission qui nous
permettra notamment de développer ça a
été dit par certains d'entre vous des
petits réacteurs modulaires qui nous
permettra monsieur Menonville de fermer
le cycle nucléaire de manière peut-être
un peu moins dispendieuse que le profil
Astrid qui était sans doute pas très mal
allez organiser et qui s'annonçait une
fois de plus comme un gouffre
que nous ne souhaitions pas les pensées
merci mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs travaillons ensemble à
l'avenir de la politique énergétique
française je suis sûr que nous pouvons y
arriver merci
merci Monsieur le Ministre maintenant
donner la parole à madame la Première
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs en conclusion de
ce débat je veux commencer par saluer
chacun des orateurs qui se sont succédés
à la tribune ce soir
les interventions ont été fortes en
idées plutôt qu'en polémique et chaque
groupe a pu exprimer sa vision des défis
devant nous
depuis le choc pétrolier dans les années
70 régulièrement les énergies fossiles
reviennent sur le devant du débat public
systématiquement elles sont synonymes de
crise de monter des prix de menaces de
pénurie et de dégâts climatiques majeurs
ce constat nous le partageons et depuis
des années nous avons son pour trouver
les moyens de sortir de notre dépendance
aux énergies fossiles
il y a quelques mois la guerre en
Ukraine a marqué une nouvelle étape
nous devons accélérer je crois que c'est
un consensus qui s'est dégagé ce soir un
consensus que j'avais déjà observé lors
des échanges que j'avais eus avec chacun
des présidents de groupe
ça n'est pas la seule Converse
convergence que j'ai observé ce soir
nous sommes tous convaincus que la
transition énergétique devra préserver
le pouvoir d'achat des Français et
confortés la compétitivité de notre
économie et je peux vous assurer
monsieur le sénateur gay nous sommes
déterminés à lutter contre la précarité
énergétique c'est notamment le sens du
chèque énergie exceptionnelle jusqu'à
200 euros pour les 40% de Français les
plus modestes en complément du bouclier
tarifaire c'est aussi le sens monsieur
le sénateur court corbisé de
l'augmentation dans le projet de loi de
finance 2023 du budget de ma prime rénov
et du maintien d'une prime à la
conversion pour permettre aux Français
notamment les plus modestes de passer un
véhicule qui consomme moins
nous sommes accordés aussi sur la
nécessité de conquérir notre
souveraineté énergétique nous ne pouvons
plus être dépendants d'autres pays et
particulièrement de ceux qui rejettent
notre modèle démocratique nous devons
être en maîtrise de notre production
c'est aussi la meilleure façon de
contrôler le niveau des prix et je vous
confirme monsieur le Président
Retailleau que nous maintiendrons le
bouclier tarifaire gaz au-delà du 1er
juillet avec un tarif de référence
prolongé pour les années suivantes et je
vous confirme également que nous
travaillons depuis des semaines pour
mettre en oeuvre ce modèle
ibérique à l'échelle européenne car
contrairement à l'Espagne nous ne sommes
pas une péninsule nous sommes fortement
interconnectés avec les autres États
membres la nécessité c'est d'avancer à
l'échelle européenne
et par ailleurs monsieur le sénateur gay
je vous confirme que nous voulons aussi
une réforme durable du marché de
l'électricité avec un découplage des
prix du gaz et de l'électricité et je
suis et je suis et je reste convaincu
que notre souveraineté passe par la
France et par l'Europe
ce soir bien sûr j'ai aussi entendu
quelques caricatures ou procèdent d'un
tension
il n'est pas forcément utile de s'y
étendre n'est pas forcément
utile de polémiquer car nous savons
aussi que ça n'est pas sûr eu une année
ou même sur quelques années que se joue
les transformations dans la filière
nucléaire elle se joue sur des dizaines
d'années ceux qui bien avant nous ont
lancé le programme nucléaire français le
savait parfaitement personne ne l'ignore
ici il y a eu au cours des 25 dernières
années pratiquement tous les cinq ans
des alternances politiques au cours de
ce chemin peut-être y a-t-il eu des
erreurs et si c'est le cas je pense à
tout le moins qu'elles sont partagées
et si nous devons être lucides il faut
l'être jusqu'au bout la France a fait le
choix de préserver son parc nucléaire il
dit investir
certains de nos grands voisins n'ont pas
fait ce choix et nous pouvons être fiers
de la confiance que nous avons toujours
placé dans notre filière nucléaire
confiances aussi dans notre grande
entreprise nationale EDF qui ne saurait
être question de démanteler
au cours de nos débats c'est au tour de
notre mix énergétique que j'ai entendu
la plus forte différence d'approche je
l'ai dit je l'ai dit tout à l'heure et
je le répète devant vous ma conviction
est un mix diversifié nous protège et
garantit notre souveraineté
car il n'existe pas d'énergie sans
défaut je le disais nous croyons
fermement au nucléaire nous sommes
convaincus qu'il s'agit de la voie de
l'efficacité de la souveraineté et de la
neutralité carbone mais nous ne pouvons
pas non plus faire croire que c'est une
énergie tout à fait banale le chantage
russe autour de la centrale de
zapporigia nous le rappelle durement
nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre non
plus de tout miser sur une seule source
d'énergie en cas d'avarie de problèmes
techniques ou de défauts nous serions
alors exposés démunis nous voulons donc
développer aussi sans hésiter les
énergies renouvelables elles sont
décarbonées bénéfiques pour notre
économie elles permettent l'émergence de
nouvelles filières industrielles et ses
apports énergétiques sont déterminants
particulièrement dans les moments de
tension cependant nous n'oublions pas
qu'elles sont intermittentes et posent
des questions d'acceptabilité
elles ne peuvent pas être seules l'alpha
et l'oméga de notre action énergétique
même si comme vous l'avez souligné
madame la sénatrice Denise Saint-Pé
elles peuvent aussi constituer un
complément de revenus pour nous
agriculteurs qu'il s'agisse de
l'agrivoltaïsme ou de la méthanisation
je crois donc à l'équilibre à la
diversification et avec mon gouvernement
nous continuerons à les défendre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs les
échanges de ce soir ouvrent une séquence
nous posons d'abord les termes de notre
débat nous aurons ensuite à discuter
dans les prochaines semaines de deux
projets de loi d'urgence pour accélérer
le développement de nos énergies
renouvelables et nous projets nucléaires
enfin une fois les débats sous l'égide
de la CNDP qui démarre actuellement
menée nous pourrons débattre en 2023
d'une noix de programmation énergies
climat je souhaite et j'espère que
l'esprit de responsabilité et la volonté
d'agir dont nous avons fait preuve ce
soir nous guiderons collectivement dans
les échanges à venir vous pouvez compter
sur moi et mon gouvernement pour écouter
chacun et chercher des compromis sur
l'énergie en particulier je suis
convaincu qu'ils sont à notre portée je
vous remercie merci madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues
je vais maintenant lever la séance notre
prochaine séance aura lieu demain jeudi
13 octobre à 10h30 pour la suite du
projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur la séance élevée